[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm I've lost count of how many threes
I've been to at this point it's just all
a blur oh yeah my third I feel like the
old guy it's number three for you Tamar
did you poop your pants during one that
I'm on my [ __ ] now on my first one I
almost ripped my pants I was my third
week working a game spot trying to like
how many thousands of people are
watching just take a quick dump on the
table now it was like cuz tyroon was
running things then and I've never
spoken to him before and he was like you
sit here you do not move if you move you
screw this all up for us and I was like
I really need to go to the toilet badly
and I was sandwiched between I think I
was next to Kevin at the time and maybe
Chris waters was in the middle when you
were on the air if you go back and watch
that stream just look into my eyes and
notice how much I'm readjusting the way
I'm saying like it was trying to
compress everything and hold it in place
long enough once I was done I took the
best
speaking of we could probably get into
what we're gonna see a CD Projekt RED
has said definitely gonna be there with
an RPG right which everybody is pretty
much sue me it's cyberpunk 2077 we still
don't exactly know what kind of game
it'll be I mean aside from an RPG
probably a cyberpunk aesthetic I would
imagine I mean we don't know if it's
gonna be in the vein of The Witcher 3
they've had a lot of success with
Witcher 3 they had it's an expansion for
Gwyn and everyone's really good that's
that's one of the bigger things that
we're expecting to definitely see yeah
I'm absolute fall at 76 between 76 today
yeah today as of this recording in both
76 our future begins there are sources
saying it's gonna be an online like
survival game inspired by dayz and rust
yeah which I find pretty cool but I
imagine there will be some backlash for
people who just want that Bethesda Game
Studios single-player RPG a lot fallout
Elder Scrolls which could still be
coming yeah I'm gonna teasing a lot of
stuff before that
and so I feel like they're holding
something back yeah they have that one
game which they're supposed to be my
co-star something like that but like
this Fallout game seems like a natural
evolution of shelter just like they did
so well with shelter it makes sense for
them to kind of scale up and given the
trend of open world kind of survival and
almost like Daisy style stuff being
everywhere right now this is the game
that feels almost best suited to do it
like even if it's rubbish
just someone should do it just to say
it's done because we need that fallout
open-world kind of like post-apocalyptic
creation game but yeah I get the feeling
that there will be some trepidation from
people who are like well are just
something different the Fallout style
well while we're on Bethesda they also
announced rage - with that trailer we
know it's gonna be an open-world kind of
game between collaboration between
Avalanche Studios and it yeah that's
about it right now we also know the
sequel to the 2009 game I'm still
surprised they're doing a sequel to that
but I guess that just like shows
something I think they're just trying to
play off the recognition of the brand
I don't expect they're actually no it is
a brand that is known okay I think it's
just that's the bare minimum I think for
a publisher like that these days
especially the idea that it's going to
be different that at least gives people
some context to get excited for because
you know best-case scenario they hold on
to what did work about rage and just
spin the rest and into somewhere new I
get the feeling like they're trying to
eat Borderlands lunch yes like just be
like because Borderlands is a game that
people really love but it's just the
kind of build up to it and the sequel
it's been so slow and weird and muddled
I get the feeling that they could really
benefit off just coming in and being
like hey we've got a crazy apocalyptic
Mad Max style game and obviously
Avalanche did Mad Max right so it's like
them being coming up and being like that
game that you like because it's kind of
mad Maxie we've actually got the people
who made the game and we taken the same
attitude and the style of it and I think
they could really slide in and eat
kind of like take some mindshare away
from Borderlands depends on the timing
yeah because it's not a 2018 game yeah
yeah but then Randy pictures was feeling
like we're not gonna be a three now
which kind of seemed like there or did
he just say Borderlands 3 I think
there'll be some so maybe there's
borderline something and we caught
Borderlands in 2/3 I mean I was true I
did a magic trick did you see it I'm
grateful magic Bethesda they've been
teasing some prey DLC news who reviewed
for GameSpot they were totally wrong it
was one of the best games always right
yeah pray they're gonna have that moon
DLC everybody's pretty much like a
poorly kept secret they've been tweeting
for like maybe six months now it
shouldn't tweet about if they want to
keep it a secret
right poorly kept secret I said but I'm
kept it'll I'm personally excited to see
what that is I really like to pray I
know there's a few of us in the office
that liked it I don't know I'm really
excited to see what they do with press
to see yeah how they add on to it
especially given how long it's been
since prey released now is anyone really
still thinking about that game or how
surprising it is that they're even doing
a DLC for that game which made almost
nothing in the grid like base from
arcane at least yeah I'm wondering if
it's gonna be like a death of the
outsider kind of standalone expansion I
mean that was what I wanted them to do
when I first played pray but then I was
like I don't know if they made enough
money to do that but then potestas been
supporting our King pretty well
throughout the years
and yeah they usually pile good DLC so
I'm excited to see I'm interested in
going back to it because I'd love to see
how they whether they follow the same
style of the game or if they kind of
switch you up in terms of tone taking
your feedback into account those down
mimics at least make them interesting in
some meaningful way my dream would be to
see deep doom - Corden yeah yeah yeah
yeah like when Pete Hines is like oh
we're gonna have our press conference
here admit Gordon was like oh really
then you quake last year they're made
yeah
champions completely forgot about right
this moment so maybe we'll see yeah
I don't know there was like a beta for
that okay all right these things yeah
but anyway moving on from Bethesda we
got EA will have anthem just this
morning as well they started they
tweeted out like it looked like kind of
a matrix looking code following place
saying decoding twice you didn't see
that yeah I don't know what that's gonna
be about it's just pretty much them
teasing that they're gonna be it III
like really interested in anything cuz
like didn't thinking about Blizzard so
much recently I can't even say any other
B words by way has really taken it hit
lately yeah yeah the star has fallen for
them this is kind of to me a big
make-or-break moment for them I can I
need to put out a solid good game that
hooks people otherwise that the
prestigious
you ready to go
just grab us with supplies just already
what are you gonna use today I decided
to go with the Colossus I'm gonna use my
ranger try out some new upgrades
yeah I'm curious to see like how you
know all the reaction to Star Wars
obviously they're not related but the
economics of a game coming out of EA
especially a big one like anthem I'm
curious to see how that's maybe shifted
I guess we'll probably never know what
might have changed and like I'm hoping
they're looking at destiny I mean
they've had two destinies to look at if
that is the type of game going for
they've had two destinies to look at and
see like what are the issues here what
do people like and kind of use that as a
jumping off point for their experience
so I'm hoping that they're doing that
and we get something a little more you
know long-term out of it I really want
to kind of think myself into a new
Bioware world yeah I played Andromeda
and it crushed my soul I don't want to
lose like everything that usually makes
a Bioware game special which is its
single-player and so I hope we kind of
get more details about how that because
what was that game they announced where
it was like there would be a
single-player campaign but it was like
the asynchronous asymmetrical
multiplayer it's like shut up round so
something like yeah and they were gonna
try and balance multiplayer I don't
think I'm with you though if they could
take what people like about destiny and
those kind of games and then implement
it into the Bioware formula which lately
hasn't really held much cloud by our
strengths its storytelling and like see
the single-player campaigns destinies
for me one of his biggest weakness is
that stuff is completely throw away for
me like I do not care about anything
that happens in destiny beyond chewing
stuff and getting new loot so if they
could come in and be like hey we've
created a good story and a proper world
for you to actually think it into you
know more meaningful than having the
traveler just floating there for no
apparent reason for years and years that
could be a big deal
for someone like me and I really hope I
love Byway and I want to see them
succeed I love most game companies and
want to see them succeed more than
anyone I want to see bio I kind of hit
their stride again because when my way
puts out a good game it's like it's a
special thing I think that struck me
when they showed it off last year was
the mobility throughout the world yeah
that's my big question mark because
that's the sort of thing that can really
in a game like that excellent feeling of
movement and and how the world can
facilitate that and allow you to go
through it right and experience all it
has to offer in different ways that's
clunky I would probably have to not even
I probably write it off even if the
story is good and it's like they don't
have a great history with mobility in
that style if you think of the gel the
Makos jetpacks but this looks so much
more they must have like brought in new
people to do it yeah that wouldn't
surprise me
good yeah the upgrade will be the GUP
grades will all be based on your exosuit
right and it's other four classes I
forget what they're actually called but
you know obviously destiny has the three
so it does seem like it is their destiny
Killoren if you want to call it that to
be reductive but yeah we'll also be
showing battlefield 5 more of it at EA
play the weekend or the weekend at the
beginning of III we saw that trailer
they showed during dices conference
which didn't really say much the trailer
looked like an action movie people that
annoyed because they didn't think I was
historically accurate which battlefield
multiplayer has never been it's cuz
they're idiots Michael yeah I know the
thing that struck me about it was it was
a little more playful than I expected it
to be like there was a bit where a guy
was like injured and a medic was running
by O'Neill's like I need a med kit and
the guy just replied like sorry mate no
time it was like weirdly fortnight ish
in terms of the way it was told and like
this is an interesting thing to lead
with for battle because usually they're
like very straight you know serious sure
doing crazy things but being like
tonally very like this is a war we're
gonna do war stuff but here is like a
little more playful which is weird for
me and I kind of like it I like that
they're leaning into it cuz it that's
ultimately what you want to do right
that gift of a guy on a horse with a
flamethrower is what I want to do
accurate I stood okay it seems like
they're being more honest about how
people play those yeah it keeps
reminding of like trevor in GTA v he's
like a character that makes sense where
Enix is having their own press
conference this year for the first time
in a few years
Kingdom Hearts 3 just probably Lucy I
know you want to talk about Kingdom
Hearts 3 I played it monk yeah couple
weeks go into the event in Santa Monica
yep got to play it like an hour like if
you are familiar with Kingdom Hearts and
you'll be fine but I am interested in
seeing how people who haven't grown up
with Kingdom Hearts are gonna take to it
because it feels very ps2 it looks
incredible hmm but also and the way they
tell the characters is great like very
very authentic like a way to do the Toy
Story characters but at the same time
they added in like just the most
incredible anime notes like they will
have a conversation and then Rex will go
or something or like yeah I don't know
and the writing is very much you know
that we took like someone's gone missing
and then you know sorrell go but he's my
friend we have to go find him it's very
very corny ja whatever but it is like
what Lisa said is a hunter who is if
feels like a Kingdom Hearts game the
cameras slightly wonky and requires a
little more micromanaging than you'd
like the combat is kind of like very
flowy and you know
this time like the chain style stuff
which if you know Kingdom Hearts it
makes perfect sense and it feels
familiar but I'm interested I think
they're gonna really lean into kind of
selling the kind of attachment to
characters more so than ever and I think
they it makes me think that they're
gonna have a lot of recent popular
characters like really focus on like the
frozen characters or the tangle
characters
yeah big hero six and use that to kind
of bring more people in well that's good
because Kingdom Hearts like like the
number just one and two and then you had
all those spin-offs and they have used
the same world to death like maybe if I
have to go to Agrabah one more time I
swear to god it's gonna be fair I don't
care about Kingdom Hearts seriously like
it's about damn time that they show
something about follow five six seven
remake yeah if they don't they've run
the serious risk of people just laughing
it then like more than they already are
they've changed teams once they they
kick cyberconnect2 out they have you
know throwing around like pretty broad
statements about what the game is gonna
be and what it's gonna entail we have to
see something and I really hope it's not
just another CGI I hope it's not but I
get a feeling it will be like there's
something about that that kind of stuff
that changing teams and that kind of
business I feel like if it required a
kind of gameplay revamp or saw all sorts
they're gonna lean on something easy
easy sellable yeah that would really I
think it fans really stoked I don't know
how much you guys care about public 87
right but like showing how the materia
system works how mixing and matching
materia can then be turned into game
play even if it's just basic examples
like that I don't need like a 20-minute
you know it's like it could you know
consecutive like gameplay recording like
get into the nitty gritty actually speak
to the fans eyes show something other
than clouds facing like do you think
they would go as hard on
if they're gonna coho I know right there
is that sort of I think yeah it's a
tough balance but they have other press
conferences as well there's obviously
Sony's they can lean into that yeah
obviously if I like I said it could
appear at any of the publisher or
platform holders press conferences
kuszleika 15 was on Microsoft and
Microsoft needs to cater to Japanese
fans I think if they want to stay
competitive or they can just continue
down the path are doing right now which
is sort of you know taking a break out
from Sony by giving people services that
work really well maybe Microsoft can do
something else along that route I don't
want to see another halo 6 I don't I
don't know what you guys I'd well I
don't care about Microsoft sequels like
that because oh my god how many more
games we need with Master Chief
specifically you know for six ah will
that's happening six and like they have
to and that's like I'd say guarantee
high halo six I would not be totally
surprised to see Gears of War 5
announced four was how many years ago -
I think that like I'm not I'm not
disagreeing about I know I know
but never like a lot of hate from people
kept saying I don't give a [ __ ] but like
seriously like do something surprising
yeah I'm serious
because like scalebound I cancelled a
couple years ago that was a new IP
they're gonna show whoring the blind
forest - which I'm really excited for
but that's not huge no and I want
Microsoft to show something like crazy I
want them to surprise people because you
know it does every other everyone else
does
yeah I want them they're gonna show helo
six are gonna show I they might show
gears were five or something I'm gonna
show Orion blind for us to I want them
to surprise us to surprise us but I
don't know what they would show right
now was it playground doing an
open-world RPG of souls that was
playground the Forza horizon guys were
hiring for a not Forza game
I think as an RPG of sorts so that could
show I feel like it's still too early
for that to pop up but that could be one
of the things that they very briefly
teased but I agree with Pia like I will
play some halo if you put some halo in
front of me but if they show you on the
stage I will not be excited another then
it could be something to do with like I
was in Sony icon gears a boy is fine
but I cannot deal with another Gears of
War being the centerpiece like they need
Microsoft really really need to show
they have games they built a lot of
momentum by you sure their new ideas
yeah yeah they build some momentum by
being like here's the Xbox one X which
is the best way to play you know 4k
games or whatever but like they've had
little to nothing to kind of like really
entice me into buying one of those I'm
fine with my current Xbox 1x I need some
new I new games need some UI piece need
some new ideas if they don't have that I
think we're gonna have a really rough
III I see the thieves was a really great
attempt yeah do something do something
as unexpected as that yeah I think
that's mine maybe not my number one
dream for this e3 but like I've I've
been pretty critical of Microsoft over
the years like a lot of people but I
think I I've always brooding for them
and I want them I think my number one
wish at this e3 is that like you said
Microsoft does something super
surprising and I'm happy coming out of
he three about Microsoft
[Music]
all right what about Sony they've got a
few things we could talk about yeah
already said ghosts of Tsushima death
stranding spider-man and most of us -
yeah probably what yeah so that's spring
2019 I believe Game Informer has had a
ton of footage I have never seen a game
like show that much yeah
footage this early oh it's more than
that - they like gave them each the
controller for a while I'm really
excited for that game I know like a lot
people are tired of zombies but I think
if they can do new things with that game
the open world survival which has been
done but if they can introduce enough
new ideas I'll be on board for that game
next year I've been begging and pleading
for a new tension game and although the
season that it's just close enough and
you know a stealth game that Studio
makes incredibly interesting open worlds
and they do traversal really well which
is one thing that we talked about before
like between infamous and sly and that
kind of stuff they do traversal so well
and the idea of like a samurai becoming
a ninja story and would this stuff they
could introduce without with freerunning
or even like I love the intent you just
grappling up onto a roof running around
and that was like my favorite thing to
do so that that game is like all my
attention is on that game I want to see
what its goal of stealth games what are
the odds we're gonna see you gameplay of
death training I say no I say no yeah
hey just play devil's advocate what
could they show anything that would
paint an idea of what this game is on
for five minutes yeah outside of
Kojima's you know like guys smart but
it's always like it seems like delusions
of grandeur at first until we see more
of whatever he's doing every time I try
to think about what that gameplay could
be I always just my frame of reference
is it old Metal Gear stuff yeah and the
only thing I can find in there is that
now we have solid three mini-games
snakes nightmare which is the weird like
action game that you wake up into and
in that a stuff so that's currently my
my kind of template for what it could be
but I don't I think that's a bit too
like open that's a bit too simple like
he's a whole like rope and stick I think
we will see gameplay of us though yeah I
feel like this will be this is the
perfect time probably show closer the
last two trailers especially the last
one we know I'm doing if they do the
similar thing now with that because
there was quite a lot of backlash to
that trailer so I wonder how they
approach showing a new trailer because
if that is the overall tone of the game
like it's really war and you know rough
and then they'd have to almost double
down on it so it could kind of define
the discussion around the press
conference if they really do double down
on it but then how are you gonna balance
that with like the levity of spider-man
like a hard cutoff where it's like
disclosure and then not a band just my
disclosure things it's been like but
this is about to get bad so spider-man
will play later this year right medium
Game Informer's showing stuff they show
a lot more than that game I'm excited
for that game yeah I liked it saw me
acts tough yeah exactly
worried about the combat but they do
travel again very well and there's some
one of the things I really hope they've
done is like that they're the amazing
spider-man games like there was two of
them
they're not great games the actor
they're not great games but they did
swinging really well in a way it did
like the behind the shoulder camera and
like when you swung you'd come really
close to the ground and it like swing
come up behind you and follow your own I
think that's got some of the most some
of the best new momentum base swinging
and Cinemax of it so I hope they're
taking a cue from that and not like
building their own combat system I don't
know how I feel they looks like more is
more environment based where you're
grabbing stuff and play around yeah that
works and it's written by in part by Dan
Slott who wrote a superior spider-man
and that is an excellent series so I'm
kind of hopeful for the actual story as
well and superior spider-man was Doctor
Octopus becoming spider-man because he
switched buddy in the P epoxy he gets
weird as well okay so it could be
interesting from a story perspective
moving on to the last of the big three
Nintendo or is the big question yeah who
the hell is making it will it actually
start saying this because there's a huge
number of rumors pointing to this new
character Silex being heavily involved
I'm a better way to switch things up and
to have that the main character he is a
bounty hunter he is Sam's his adversary
maybe they could work in tandem or maybe
they'll be against each other I would
love to see something crazy like that
one of my favorite Metroid games I know
it's not a popular one is Metroid Fusion
yeah and like the evil Samus right I'd
love if they did that like proper lean
into the survival horror angle and I
have like an Evo Samus again like
parasite eggs and it's rolling around in
metroid primes though or maybe have sama
since Alex's backyard and have socks
just sure that the screw with you yeah
to be a menace like another character
like the Nemesis from Resident Evil or
parasites Emerson that is one of my
favorite games and I'd love for them to
switch you up I would love a different
character because it's I love when
serious
a different take on on a character you
love and you know maybe I started to
write and everyone hates writing but the
great thing about writing is you get to
experience what it's like to be next to
snake yeah and there's few characters as
like competent and like revered as samus
so to be able to see her like operate
from another person's perspective would
be really interesting especially in a
game like program yeah I think this will
be this match and maybe some like Mario
stuff I as much as it don't know we're
gonna see much crime just last night as
it's recording we saw all the Pokemon
let's go Pikachu let's go Eevee news as
well as what Pokemon quests today so
that's not the switch makes you switch
the title they've been working on do you
think they'll show anything off with
that III especially coming off these
announcements last night so soon after I
think they might leave these ones to
breathe and then they'll do a cursory
like oh but you know we still working on
this I think the way that the Pokemon go
the two new go games look is that they
actually look what I was imagining a
switch Pokemon game yeah it look like so
I don't imagine they could go too far
away from that and really wow us yeah so
yeah like you said let these breathe and
sort of use this as the foundation and
take the learnings from it to then it
seems like they're well they've said
they're also trying to introduce the
huge Pokemon go audience into more
mainstream or maybe not mainstream into
more mainline Pokemon games especially
with the actual capturing a [ __ ] on
in the game is more go influence it just
sell switches so those people buy other
games too because remember last year
they reveal the new Metroid game with no
one was looking know anything so we go
fantastic they could do some of the
things with that like I imagine it's
gonna be the smash show mostly but
people should be keeping an eye on the
treehouse stuff after but yes they
always do bring back Wario Ware they've
already talked about were you really on
3d yes
you think we'll see anything else from
the 3ds aside from that yes yes Tendo is
not yeah I'm glad I loved it yes but as
far as smash goes you are you of the
mind that it'll just be the Wii U
version with new characters put on the
switch or like full-on Super Smash Bros
skirmish brouhaha they'll build on top
of this with the Wii U foundation
there'd be no reason to scrap it I don't
think anyone thinks that it's like worth
starting over oh yeah yeah I think the
Wii U version aside from melee is like
one of the more revered ones yeah and
then they could tweak it a little bit
they wouldn't have such a scratch yeah
there's like a fresh coat of paint and
you can I mean they've been making the
same game for years like so I'm sure if
they gave us the exact same game on
switch most people would be happy but
they'll go into a bit press conference
that we didn't talk about third-party
Ubisoft division 2 is probably their big
thing which I'm actually excited for
return to the division recently and
after all those updates I mean it was a
good game to begin with it just wasn't
what a lot of people expected I think a
lot of people expect its
post-apocalyptic coop open-world story
driven kind of thing I'm actually pretty
excited for the division to to see what
they do specifically with the dark zone
because that was a cool idea that was
like they're you know they're they're
shared multiplayer you can kind of turn
on people it was almost like a more
in-depth battle royale mode you could
turn on people you can help them out
usually it was a little bit broken when
it first came out and now they've
refined it but I'm curious to see what
they do with the division 2 to kind of
build upon the foundation it reminds me
of destiny because it was a lot of the
ideas there were new
it didn't just seemed like they were
shaped to the way they needed to be I'm
curious if they'll go the Destiny to
route and kind of backtrack a little bit
and annoy some people or if they'll just
keep building on the solid foundation
they've built especially after all those
expansions
really interesting is like between that
and films a lot of similar experiences
coming over
I mean they know committing to games a
long time so I expect to spend some time
on the existing games like for on a
siege definitely there should be some
awesome stuff don't have third year
whatever it's gonna have one last push
for crew two second yeah I don't know if
they how come it today - that they are
maybe yeah like apparently that like
like division that game has changed
significantly and it's really good now
it's one of those games that I've been
meeting to go back to but that could get
like that if they want to show off that
game and show like oh this is better no
and it's really cool
no okay which looks huge it's like an
actual world but then they have Mars and
zombies yeah I don't know what the order
is I think I'd mix those two up I really
want to see Splinter Cell along with I
know like okay because it died on
yourself and it seems about time and
it's also they put Sam Fisher in Ghost
Recon wildlands yeah of all games I
would love to see them do a new main
line Splinter Cell last one with
blacklist which I really liked
it's not my favorite but it was really
good I would like to see them do
something new with that it's been a
while I thought you were saying Elijah
Wood would be in the new spoiler so he
Sam Fisher's son and Sam has to kind of
like train him to be an operative what
about what about they're like any
watchdogs in the Assassin's Creed this
year Assassin's Creed origins was last 2
years ago probably it was last year they
took a year up I'm curious to see if
they can build on the momentum of
origins or if they'll fall back into
that lackadaisical annual release
malaise they talked about like there was
a lot of discussion about Assassin's
Creed moving towards of Witcher
direction and I think like if they I
hope they continue to move towards that
way I think origins was a good start for
it
nothing like some stronger quests and
stronger dialogue and like
kind of cleaning up the way kind of its
presented and like the ruffle it's
moving on the rough edges they if they
keep going towards that I think they'll
be in a good place and hopefully like
this years if they have won it will be
another step towards sir I'm excited to
see where they go cuz it's gonna be good
indication of what Assassin's Creed
future will look like
so if there's gonna be a Sanskrit you
probably wouldn't expect anything from
watchdogs for a while then watchdogs to
did well right and so I think they'll
take the time to build a build on that
and do something different they want to
move another see again and introduce new
characters and stuff so good evil oh
yeah I couldn't like after their
announcement did nothing for me in fact
it actually turned me off it's just it
just seemed like everything that
everyone loved about Beyond Good and
Evil digits missing raped out watching
his dreams that they're doing as well
it's just like they're speaking and they
say stuff in the showing like 20 second
long clips and I can't get a feel for
what it is and that every original
trailer when they were like the monkeys
are swearing and well he's like oh you
could go to there from the ground to the
ship and I was like what happened to
just taking pictures about horns and
hearing people with a stick so when do
they were first announced that that was
like lost was that last year that's last
year inflation yeah I saw I went to see
it and that game did not exist
like I was looking at it that was not a
game it was an idea that someone had
very quickly called together in an
engine and I they showed me pictures
like this is artwork for it and I date
there was no clear vision of oil would
be you know answer was they're talking
and it was like what Lizzie was saying
he was speaking what he was saying was
no making sense at all and I don't feel
like they would
any meaningful well I feel like they're
kind of like they trying to cash in on
trends almost like these open-world
stuff and you freedom and that kind of
business but I don't know why they've
decided to attach beyond good and evil
to to it like it's I mean the reason I
mean that is the reason yeah but like it
seems like a really weird thing to do
like it's gonna on here anything about
it yeah maybe we want I feel like if
they did it will be another short thing
like a trailer and they'll talk about
they'll talk a lot about it but we will
still leave that presentation not
knowing what Beyond Good and Evil 2 is
and worst case not one thing beyond evil
- alright as far as what I'm most
excited for I don't know if it's gonna
be there I would love to see a new main
line Splinter Cell that is my I think
that's my dream announcement this III
yeah tomorrow what are you most excited
for like I spent so again but another
stealth game and that studio is
incredible so I'm excited for Gossett
Tsushima who's you about you I want to
see more of Last of Us and I want a
release date for Kingdom Hearts it's
been twelve yes it's been 12 years and
you recently played it which to be
honest I did not expect me I warned you
it was it was a moment like you put the
headphones on I was like okay I still
care it was they played dearly beloved
at the title screen and I remembered
that I care how much I cared about it
when it's like playing and I was like
yeah it's cuz I played to a very
formative part of my life and I just
feel like that's I'm so intrinsically
tied to at least Burke's on that game
yeah I judge it and also it's because
it's taking the basemap I'm the same
with no get to so whenever I see riding
this flip on bird [ __ ] I'm like if for
me I'm just a Nintendo dork I really
want to see exactly everything they're
going to show if I had to sort of assume
that someone announced things you know
would materialize I would hope it is a
Zelda on 3ds that incorporates some of
the elemental mixing from breath of the
wild any interesting way I think that
that could be a thing if they want to
keep people interested in through yes
it's always probably the way to do it
I mean between worlds like going back a
3d house is one of my favorite Zelda
I mean well hopefully this one cool well
III zijn what as of this recording III
reason like 10 days 10 days well I'm
looking forward to it and I'm hoping we
see more just dance I will do my best
and don't prove yourself yeah at least
when I'm on got no promises for the last
two decades some of the biggest gaming
news and reveals have come during the
Electronic Entertainment Expo or e3 the
yearly video game industry trade show
where the newest titles and products are
on full display many for the first time
but even though the show has drawn tens
of thousands of people to its convention
centers every summer the show itself has
gone through a whole lot of changes
during this 22-year long run so let's
take a look back at the history of III
and maybe laugh at all the dorky 90s
outfits while we're at it
strap yourself in cuz we're gone III
okay so here we are in 1985 the gaming
industry was attempting to recover from
the market crash two years prior and CES
the Consumer Electronic Show was the
primary convention for Hardware makers
to show off the newest consoles and
games video games would continues to
thrive after the release of the Nintendo
Entertainment System
but there still wasn't a dedicated
gaming convention for all the newest
releases for the next ten years they had
to share the spotlight with the latest
televisions cameras and the Batmobile
and so that brings us to 1995 right in
the middle of the decade a 19-year old
Tiger Woods was dominating the amateur
golf world
Bill Gates was busy launching the newest
version of Windows with Jay Leno for
some reason but more importantly the
interactive digital software association
now known as the Entertainment Software
Association or ESA was quietly putting
together the biggest video game
tradeshow in the world I'm Kurt Loder
with MTV News connoisseurs of video
games computer effluvia and all the
latest in electronic gizmo mania
converged on Los Angeles last week the
annual Electronic Entertainment Expo
that are known as e3 okay 50,000 members
of the press in its first year is hardly
quiet
in fact the gaming world got an earful
of big console announcements from the
three biggest publishers at the time
Sony Sega and Nintendo during e3 1985
Sony revealed the original Playstations
release date and price the Sega Saturn
for some reason started immediately
shipping to retailers and Nintendo
showcased the Virtual Boy
I guess one out of three ain't bad and
that was in addition to all the
third-party developers who also show
them 3do Capcom
Activision EA and squaresoft all
attended but their presence was dwarfed
by none other than acclaim who brought
in over 15 different games to the show
III s first year ended up being one of
the biggest game conventions to date and
encouraged the organizers to continue
having the show in Los Angeles every
summer and they did for the next two
years at least while sunny California
might have been the perfect spot for e3
due to some unfortunate negotiation
problems the location was actually moved
to Atlanta Georgia for 97 and 98
nevertheless III continued to grow
inside
and upon returning to the LA Convention
Center the attendants remain at a steady
60 to 70 thousand people strong that's
quite a lot of people but there were
quite a lot of games there as well III
99 featured Sega's new Dreamcast console
in full force as well as some previews
of Sony's new Playstations at e3 2012
computer software giant Microsoft who
are preparing for the release of their
first video game console the Xbox win
that box
III 2001 was the final appearance of
Sega as a console maker after making the
decision to focus on software only but
we also got the first look at Nintendo's
leda system the Gamecube as well as the
first trailer for super smash brothers
melee which by the way is still one of
the biggest fighting games today so the
new big 3 Sony Nintendo and no Microsoft
kind of cruised along for a few years it
wasn't until III 2006 that Sony decided
to make history with one of the weirdest
press conferences ever game is powered
by Namco it's Ridge Racer Ridge Racer
remember that one the stages of the game
will also be based on famous battles
which took actually took place in
ancient Japan so here's this giant enemy
crab was the unintentional goofiness of
Sony's press conference the tipping
point probably not but the giant enemy
crab sure didn't help anything switch
over to Yoshi tonight
hop on its stomach
and new attack its weak point for
massive damage the following year citing
budget issues among some publishers then
ESA president Doug Lowenstein announced
that III would now be a smaller more
intimate event with an invite-only list
of about 10,000 people
this shift essentially shut out many
bloggers and non industry professionals
that had attended the show in previous
years but with a new look also came a
new name
III media and business summit also III
that year wasn't held at the typical Los
Angeles Convention Center nor was it
held in any sort of central location at
all it was actually spread across
different venues and locations in Santa
Monica and if you weren't part of the
industry at the time you probably
wouldn't have even realized it was
happening gone were the gaudy displays
and sensory overload of previous years
and in their place where hotel ballrooms
and Jamie Kennedy from Neversoft which
wasn't that the first name for viagra
despite the changes being made to try
and improve the show it was still an
exceedingly tough time for III with
Simms creator Will Wright saying that
the conference quote almost feels like a
zombie at this point but hey at least we
got a few memes out of the deal my body
my body is ready thankfully for Will
Wright and many other people who once
enjoyed attending III the show was
actually opened back up to a larger
audience in 2009 with over 40,000 people
coming back to check out the latest
games such as Metal Gear Rising Final
Fantasy 14 and Super Mario Galaxy 2 the
slight misstep didn't seem to matter all
that much as e3 continued to be the
biggest name in gaming trade shows
though there has been no shortage of
awkward press conferences in the years
since
[Music]
there was Ubisoft's in 2015 do you have
a Mimi what up you want to pitch we had
mr. caffeine in 2011 everyone do it with
me
and of course Konami's in 2010 this is
not the originally hack-and-slash
anymore this is an extreme heck of a
saddle but as we all know III isn't
about memes mostly with a 22-year
history behind it there have also been
changes in the way publishers approached
the show
companies like Ubisoft have continuously
attempted to bring more personality and
humor to their press conferences though
their success rate is up for debate and
Nintendo stopped doing live press
conferences entirely in 2013 to focus on
their pre-recorded showcases dubbed a
Nintendo Direct and in 2017 III itself
changed everything by opening its doors
to the public for the very first time
meaning that anyone was able to buy
tickets and attend the show but even
through all its ups and downs
III has been and continues to be a place
for media publishers and now the gaming
public to gather and celebrate video
games and all their wonderful and
sometimes weird glory so here's two more
III two more jaw-dropping reveals more
awkward moments and goofy press
conferences and most importantly more
games next check out our full body
motion capture so as you can see when I
start making move into my avatar
it instantly makes me on screen you ever
wonder what the bottom of an avatar shoe
looks like what BAM there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm John Warner games record for
anthem here is the world premiere of
anthems gameplay
[Music]
freelancer Braxley
listen big trouble big trouble what did
you do mistake I hired some people they
weren't freelancers I know they said
they could handle it and the price was
right
I thought maybe unbelievable you're
right
it was stupid I'm sorry but they're
still out there somewhere
if you could just bring them back
anything you need in the world of anthem
you and your friends are freelancers the
heroes who leave the safety of the walls
of port Tarsus to explore the unknown
and protect humanity
let's join two players as they head out
on an expedition you ready to go I'm
just grabbing some supplies just furedi
what are you gonna do today
I always go with the Colossus I'm gonna
use my ranger try out some new upgrades
every player will own an array of
exosuits we call javelins these suits
give players superhuman capabilities and
are heavily customizable so they look
and play how you want nice you've got a
mortar equipped yeah I got on the
weekend
this is a vast open world you explore
with your friends each javelin exosuit
has its own unique play style the Ranger
is balanced in all purpose while the
Colossus is a tanking powerhouse
the world of anthem is hostile and
threats can come from any direction
dynamic world was unexpected it's around
every corner yeah he seems like a
problem
the heavy
there
have you been in there yet
we should do that later with Kim yeah
you could use the XP
hello treasure
I think we got some actual bad
and we're under attack anyone in the
area we're under attack
you can equip your javelin exosuit with
gear that brings devastating power to
combat
oh there are a lot of scars down there
all the scars have a heavy have time use
that mortar
there's a bunch more coming
large scale world events like shaper
storms are dynamic and pull you off the
beaten path with the promise of new
stories to discover shapers Darmon
coming ok
actually let's get some more people hold
on a sec hey guys
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well Prescott hey everyone welcome to
GameSpot's coverage of e3 2018 we are
gonna be live with EA's press conference
about half an hour but first we are
gonna be talking here at GameSpot about
our hopes and dreams for the press
conference and pretty much kickoff
coverage for the next what six days
so welcome I'm Mike Mahoney here with
Lucy James hello Rob handler how are you
and tomorrow saying hello we've got
about half an hour to talk over ei
there's kind of a lot to talk about
actually Rob you're a huge Star Wars fan
you think we're gonna see well we
definitely will see what was it the one
ea motives been working on that or what
respawns doing right yeah because a
response said they're gonna say Vince
Zampella yesterday was tweeting saying
we're gonna we have something about our
one of three projects in the works that
we'll be talking about so that's either
what titanfall 3 the Star Wars game or
some feel that VR like a super realistic
yeah
titanfall 3 we saw some weird disturbing
rumors just maybe maybe not disturbing
we saw some rumors about Battle Royale
yesterday wondering there was a it's not
even worth talking about in a way it
looked really fake but it was like a
very use the same art style as like fort
and I had the same like looks like a
battle royale yeah I saw it on the
titanfall subreddit which I love because
I love that game so much I officially
bought respawn what was that last year
two years ago last year I think so
people were a bit worried about what
they would do with loot crate's and
whatnot but I think they've based on
battlefield 5 which we can also talk
about dices saying they've learned a lot
from battlefront twos like loop rocks
quite significantly so yeah I expect
games like titanfall 3 or whatever it
may be and future first-person shooters
from dice and and yeah for a little
while
won't have any major microtransaction
monetization and stuff like that they
need to earn some goodwill before they
start thinking about bringing that back
in and I'm sure that they need to
they're gonna spend a few years doing
that thankful to had it down to as far
as their microtransactions just pure
really cosmetic if you want that
secondary skin yeah but gladly because I
love the game you know that's it's a
cool distinction is like to be able to
like support a game in that way yeah if
you really care about it really quick
before we get deeper into like
discussion about the games we do have a
hashtag game spot III set up Lucy right
now throughout the show's gonna be
monitoring if you're watching and want
to participate whether you want to make
predictions talk about talking points
for ei specifically or tomorrow
Microsoft Bethesda and then Sony Square
etc just send them in to that hashtag
GameSpot also retweeted a couple of us
just respond to any of us or e3 with
questions comments concerns etc and Lucy
will shower
yeah I'm my phone she has since given up
on yeah yeah okay so we have Nicolas six
four seven seven seven says is Dragon
Age for getting announcement hmm Mike
Laidlaw is going but that doesn't mean
he's not even working out dragon a dream
alright if you want to talk about
Bioware stuff then you big things gonna
be anthem yeah we know that Casey
Hudson's down who else Mike Darrow's
gonna be there the release date
apparently has leaked yeah they are
gonna be shown a lot I think of anthem
especially like yeah been saying like Oh
a play we're gonna show you gameplay
we're gonna be focusing on the javelin
like the suits right we're gonna be you
know going in-depth and kind of
exploring the world a little bit more so
I'm excited to see more from anthem know
for sure I want to know if it's gonna
have that Bioware magic like if it's
gonna actually yeah they're gonna go
full in on trying to take down destiny
the division or are they actually gonna
introduce a narrative which like Bioware
needs a win yeah we talked about this in
our previous available now on GameSpot's
youtube channel we talked about how it's
kind of a big make-or-break moment for
fly away maybe not in the future of the
studio but the identity of the studio
they've always been known for creating
these incredibly deep you know
well thought-out worlds that have
characters and a really engaging an
intricate story but every attempt at
that for the past few games has been
kind of muddled and hasn't really hit in
a big way like Dragon Age Inquisition is
a great game in a bunch of different
ways but it hasn't kind of like they
didn't have this the strength in
storytelling and character that I feel
yeah the other the other did similar fun
drama and drama I mean we were saying
the same thing about Andromeda I was
saying in drama it was a make-or-break
moment for them because I personally
didn't think too highly of the
Inquisition I know I know a lot of
people did I felt like it was a little
bit lifeless compared to what made
Dragon Age what made my tailor public
which made their previous series great
even like Jade Empire I liked but that's
to go back wait for well farther back
but I do man like they need something
because again Mass Effect Andromeda at
that point I was saying that needs to be
great and yeah we know how that I think
I was at the same catch but then kind of
we rationalized it by saying it wasn't
the main studio that we all loved you
know it's a new studio there's there's
kind of like circumstances that you can
kind of sweep that under the rug with
new studio a bunch of people trying to
you know follow up the end of the NARC
with something new this is by a way like
the course to do that we know and love
like a lot of them are many studios are
involved but like this is kind of like
their thing like if these guys don't
make it land then we've got a problem
yeah identity by our Montreal
specifically who work on my second drama
no has since dispersed and tilt like yes
and now but the lead writer on Mass
Effect Andromeda is working on anthem
yeah which doesn't immediately concern
me because again I don't think anthem is
going full on and like pure RPG
obviously they're trying like you know
like to be reductive it looks like it a
destiny killer for everything we know
it's got what four different rigs
classes you can use but it looks I'm
super into I mean the gameplay didn't
show a ton last year but what we saw
like Robbie you were just timing up at
rehearsal with a jet packs and whatnot
that what's dope it looks so dope like
if that's really the case here right
like you know if you get hit by
anti-arab
to avoid it like that mobility that Iron
Man esque Iron Man yeah like those
exoskeletons exciting I think that one
of the key differentiators
for this could be like story you know
you said just now
oh I you know they might not be leaning
too hard into it from my perspective
they should lean really hard into the
story because one of the Destiny's
biggest failings for me is the story is
to me incomprehensible and the way that
Bioware can really kind of differentiate
and distinguish their take on it is by
having this world that's like engaging
and gives people a reason to stick
around longer than you know that they do
with destiny where it's like we're gonna
play for long enough to do a raid the
new expansion bits and then we're done
they want to aim to be war of Warcraft
where they have the gameplay they have
the loot they have all that stuff but
it's the world and the characters and
the law that people really stick around
yeah in a big way I lose you got a
question yeah no I mean like it was just
directly leading on from that K
underscore custom props was asking does
anthem have a single-player mode or is
it just multiplayer so I think this is
where we're gonna get clarification on
where those two are going to intersect
from what it looks like the way that
this first gameplay demo they showed
works like you can just do things by
yourself and your friends can seamlessly
drop in and out I'm interested in that
but like I feel like the single play
stuff for me needs to have some kind of
consequence beyond loot like I need to
have different story options different
quests open to be based on hopefully
decisions that I get to make as a player
I want to bone aliens wanna bone aliens
you perform I'm by the way you know
that's here's me a Krogan we're looking
at two of the rigs right now it's always
during the pre-show where your fetishes
come out tomorrow so this this what we
talked about this traversal looks
awesome this looks like it could be one
of the differentiators I love the idea
that everyone's like can you really make
a superman game and bio it like yeah we
did it here we go actually a good
question from at this the underscore
Seth underscore within is should I be
worried about anthem being a
disappointment like no man's sky or
destiny due to developers and directors
leaving and like if you have looked at
it anthem has had quite the turnover in
a smaller face but I mean I or in
general
recently it's I think it's heartening to
have as a Casey that rejoined recently
and Bioware and that to me was a moment
where it felt like someone recognized
that they were in desperate need of
leadership and someone to step in that
understands vision and can take a
product or a game experience and carry
it through to fruition so like having
him involved definitely gives should be
in a reason to have a little more
confidence or faith in it nevertheless
like that that element of people leaving
one after the other is unsettling but
that happens all the time it just so
happens that it happens in most studios
it just so happens that by the way is a
big enough studio that people are paying
attention to it's certainly more of a
spotlight yeah exactly so when people
leave an anthem is a huge game that a
lot of people are keeping a close eye on
so and small you know changes happen
within the studio and within the game
they're in the spotlight way more than
they would be with any other game so
yeah I would say anthem is one of those
games I am like rooting for those games
like I'm in general I'm rooting for
Microsoft to like come out and show us
some surprises but again that's neither
here nor there right now there's a plug
but yeah anthem I can't
I'm really excited like it's funny like
you were you've been pretty excited for
that all along I mean we all have but
like the closer we get like you're
watching last year's gameplay reveal the
more we talked about like the [ __ ] the
failings of destiny especially destiny
too and like the you know the grief that
dusty two players have been giving
Bungie for taking a few steps back since
the taking king days yeah and then of
course they're gonna show what's that
called forsaken it's the next one
they're gonna be talking about who knows
what they'll do with that at this point
but I hope anthem does really well a
good buy away game is just incredible
for the entire industry has been how
long since we go I mean again you could
argue there's merits with Inquisition I
personally didn't love it but I think it
was objectively a decent game dude
trespasser DLC was really I never played
that credible and if and if this series
goes from like the where the ending of
that DLC left off like I think it's
gonna be a strong so the tweets there's
a lot of them guys skate full
Hey I have you heard about that
Instagram their Instagram account for ei
everything even her about this
everything they ever put on there it's
littered like thousands and thousands of
comments on skateboard every time like
they have to be aware they actually make
good on it I just don't know like it's
gonna be tricky for them right like they
didn't stand back and they see Tony Hawk
come back and try and play a new game
all right
the problem with that Tony Hawk game was
it was bad do we have skate fans on set
right now I I liked I don't blame the
appeal of okay I don't mean to explain
the appeal I like Robin saying explain
the die-hard dedication of skate to me I
think skate is the darksouls of skating
game I played it as someone who really
didn't like I'm not a fan of skating I'm
not good at skating yeah it was just
something weirdly like intricate about
playing skate it was mechanically or
mechanically it reminded me of like I
you know most people love to dig into
systems and you know kind of kind of
figure out the upper ends of how you
achieve like little kick flips and that
kind of stuff yeah it was really
difficult and although I didn't play for
a really long time I think the physics
is what really got me okay it was funny
to me like to try and do a trick and
absolutely destroy my face or fall over
yeah like really really screw it up so
that was like fun it had limited like
kind of longevity for me I gave up after
there you know the slapstick wore off
fans coming after you yeah no I think
skate like vest tomorrow same on Twitter
I think there's definitely room for a
skate game but I don't know if there's I
don't know if the investment mode the
worry is like that the market is such a
niche that EA would look at how many
people realistically would buy a skate
game given the history and then kind of
scale development to meet that and in
that story
like you're not gonna get a super crazy
like in my mind if they put a skate game
out it would be a digital only skate
game that's kind of using the assets of
an old skate game maybe oppressed in
some capacity and maybe that's enough
maybe that's fine if I was then just
remaster skate just find an old one and
like remaster or something like that
well the chat is also asking about
remasters fel I don't know how to
pronounce that at fpg ow
do you think they will do remastered
versions of any of the Mass Effect games
or the Jade Empire game well related to
skate as well do you think they would
chef's related to dead space I don't
think that's gonna happen but of course
visceral is not an entity anymore
unfortunately
but that was my theme this morning when
I got when I when I woke up I was saying
what is my like dream of III no no sorry
not III well maybe EA a reap I would
okay my dream is like a new dead space
obviously I think that's the best-case
scenario but without without visceral I
would be pretty apprehensive about it
but dead space remastered the whole
trilogy would be I would
that's what EA could do that would make
me happy yeah that space one at the
least that's the best dead space in my
opinion but the whole trilogy they would
be amazing I would absolutely love a
Mass Effect remaster of the entire
series just in for modern concept great
yeah the first one is it
yeah like the econ go back and play them
well you can you can play one xbox one
yeah but like at the same time I just
feel there is so much love for that
franchise for the old games especially
and I feel like not remastering them
when I drama it was coming out as a real
missed opportunity
yeah because they know that the market
is there for that I would love a
remaster of the Mass Effect series my I
think they would more be inclined to do
that around the time and next Mass
Effect thing happens to kind of like
build momentum for that again they have
such like a PR hurdle with any Mass
Effect pretty much shelved the Mass
Effect for now so it could be it could
be years before we see a new Mass Effect
and in that scenario I think it might be
a while before we get a new Mass Effect
remaster collection I would love it
though because I I have the urge to play
that series normally just having it's
like it's
it should be their Skyrim like just put
it out on everything people always want
to play it and like just put it out so
who knows Rob I know you've been pretty
much itching to talk about battlefield
another huge title we've got people down
in LA today playing right cuz they play
like a little bit later today yeah we
got Aaron a few people down there Tony's
down there but you were on the
livestream for battlefield 5 reveal that
he dice did which they didn't really say
much about the game but behind closed
doors Aaron heard a lot about it it
sounds like they're going in a cool
direction despite all the dumb
controversy around that reveal trailer
in terms of like tone that trailer we
were all kind of like it looks a little
too action II but I know I think I
different from people the ops I the more
I thought it was like it feels like
they're being pretty honest about how
people play those games which I like but
of course we're going back to world war
two but what are your impressions
overall about the game overall I think
it's smart because I yeah I can't I
can't deny that when I first sounds like
oh really like they're you know they're
really going for as far as you know
prosthetics and this this trailer can I
say one thing is it's the one long
tracking shot that I find frustrating
showing off it's showing up Scorsese so
ridiculous but that is battlefield
you're right on that respect but I think
he like it's it's meeting a lot of tones
that I would want to see when you really
think about you know World War two call
duty was last year and I was very
serious I think even though it's been so
long since we've gone back to World War
two I feel like that's still tired in a
way and I think they're also meeting to
a best of two worlds here with fans who
are love bad company right
yeah that's humor that ridiculousness of
just that I think watch I have a plane
like I'm glad you brought up Call of
Duty World War two because I think that
was a missed opportunity to use World
War two again as a comeback for World
War two I mean I think they just I think
it was a very boring game in general
even if our Call of Duty I mean which is
like you know like kind of live and die
by their multiplayer for most people but
this looks great like you can what
you're you're actually like outfitting
an entire company instead of one
character completely in control of
cosmetics but of course this this trail
was supposedly Aaron was saying dice and
EA were saying most things you seen this
trailer are trying to indicate something
about multiplayer so he's talking about
fortifications are a big deal as far as
there's like crafting and such so you
can do only crafting anyone can like
build trenches barbed wire sandbags
around I guess fortifications so I would
imagine flags have two points and it's
it's an it's a nice addition to you know
you looked at like some like battlefield
one where some arguments run like that
san quintin map when scars yeah we're
you could level the entire map in a way
with because it's destructible and then
you got no cover right so in this game
they're implementing sandbag so you can
rebuild a house and a lot of summer got
around flag so you have actually similar
a lot of flags we're like useless like I
mean they they got you points and
tickets but outside of that they had no
strategic purpose this sounds like you
can this sounds like it gives me the
option as a person who plays defensively
in games like that I know it's not RTS
but I like turtle and RTS I like to like
capture stuff and hold it this time
sounds like that's an actual viable
option it's not gonna be this flag in
the corner of the map and no one's gonna
go do it aside from getting points a
question from Twitter hashtag if you're
using hashtag GameSpot III we're gonna
read you read out your tweets really
questions your predictions LP got 84
what's the chances that battlefield 5
will have a battle royale mode I really
hope not
could we get a jar every actual
announcement or question a question huge
jar there were actually reports about
this and the reports were saying that
all of this is obviously unconfirmed
reports were saying that the a battle
royale mode is being tested by dice
they're trying to figure out whether
they can make it work so it I'm reticent
say that they'll talk about it today nor
even show it off or even mention it in
interviews coming up that they have
throughout eve III unless prompted most
will get we're looking into it or it's
something we're considering because that
is very much what they're doing
I imagine like they it's probably of all
the games that you can think of it's the
best sorta like for it right yeah it's
got the open map it's got all the
different items and classes and ways to
get around
and the scale the scale of it yes the
pressure points call duty you know like
that feels a little bit of a more of a
little stretch yeah like you know
15-minute games is what I think of Call
of Duty interesting thing is gonna be
how they release it because mariah is
very much dominating the first-person
shooter like language right now everyone
wants to be part of it and you have some
stiff competition the most successful
game out there but who knows how long
that's gonna last so if they did gonna
do what everyone thinks which is
introduce it later on down the line
it could be trickier for them the longer
they wait they're worse off I feel like
they are like they want to strike while
the iron's hot and be part of the
conversation when it's happening but
also kind of leverage the mocking and
the kind of buzz around the new
battlefield itself so personally I think
that they should I would want them to do
it sooner rather than later but I still
think that we won't be seeing much of it
until now I I get a feeling that is
gonna be showing theirs off presumably
well we know black ops 4 has been around
what's that called I forget the name of
the mode specifically my black black out
black out thank you yes and they're
gonna be showing that they already have
more competition in addition to a
fortnight pub G but you mentioned yeah
you mentioned battlefield being the
franchise itself in the structure being
well suited for battle rail and I agree
especially where we're sorry battlefield
5 it seems like the grand operations
mode specifically Aaron was telling us
behind closed doors they were telling
him that they are gonna be focusing on
supplies and survival so again it
increases your the usefulness of flags
and capture points but that also your
ammo will carry over into the next round
yeah you end with one magazine you'll
have just one magazine the next round in
grant operations so it sounds like at
first I was really optimistic it sounded
like they were taking aspects of battle
rail and putting them into battle field
rather than just putting battle field
into a battle royale that makes any
sense at all
but like and that excited me because I
like battle rail and I think as opposed
to I know you were just saying like
people a lot of people are worried it's
a bubble at my purse and your I think I
agree with you like if they want to get
in on it I think they should strike
while the iron's hot
I think it could just become this
ubiquitous it already is ubiquitous mode
but like it could become just as
ubiquitous as like Team Deathmatch
future in shooters and rather like the
conversation revolving around Battle
Royale I would rather see you know games
continue to innovate like Battlefield it
sounds like it's doing sounds like
they're focusing on the right aspects
and then just like having like you said
battle rail down the road rather than
being the focus just beat us hey this is
a great bonus it also just from what
you're saying it's almost sounds like
they're cherry-picking in a nice way
where it's not like a mode that you can
see in a list but it's like yeah the
scarcity of ammo which they are doing I
believe they tweeted something the other
day about like I can't remember exactly
but it was they're showing images of
like airborne troops launching out by
means of spawning just little snippets
of what Bal Royale is and yeah and what
makes it interesting because like I
think they they also said they're gonna
they're gonna ditch the you know in bout
with one it's like the the zoom out when
you die and the zoom back in they're
gonna drop that kind and have spawn
points that aren't necessarily you
instantaneously like me on the field but
like having a cool kind like a cinematic
drop you know with a couple buddies like
to capture a point like I seems really
neat the DNA of Battle Royale has always
been within battlefield as an experience
and I think like of all the games that
are gonna be attempting it has the kind
of best chance of really striking it
rich and doing something big with it the
the audience for it is primed they know
how to play that experience way and like
the great thing about for the most part
dices games are polished
battlefield perhaps more than others
yeah because of the scale of it it has
its moments where yeah - like server
issues it some watches one thing that's
the one thing I'm really interested in
like a fully-formed
polished Balor experience instead of one
that is iterating all the time because
that's something that I struggled with
with you know pub G and even fortnight a
lot of ways like I came in and it's like
this is an experience that is rough
around the edges but in many many many
ways by the first but I feel like the
first company are really polished and
you know non buggy kind of like this is
almost as good as their single-player or
multiplayer yeah anything could could
really draw some attention away from the
other Titans of
of the genre like pub G and for tonight
yeah and I think for tonight is at the
crux of all that because they are more
polish and everything I think they are
nailing it as far as and it's also a
free game so as far as the public
getting into it but man that game is
such it one thing I have to see I want
to know about battlefield is runways
yeah want in this games Bob's our
resident pilot for any game that allows
him to be especially battlefield from
back in the 1942 Oh three days that was
when like game important a little bit of
a problem growing up or yelled a bunch
my parents like I'm more interested in
this battlefield than ever before
because one of the things that I
struggle with battlefield is I'm that
the scale is too big for me like I'm one
of those people who will spawn somewhere
like and then get shot by a sniper and
that was a problem in battlefield one
specifically yeah and like the idea of
introducing like gadgets and weird back
tech and that kind of stuff class your
claws and weird like really leaning into
the madness it gives you something to
kind of do in the moments where you're
running into a battle for example or
like something to think about
just to standard military warfare
infantry boots on the ground stuff is
not interesting to me immersive
immersive that stuff is it very quickly
loses interest way and running across a
map only to get killed instantly by
someone who's been waiting for me to run
by something sniped while you're
parachuting down no but there's also
combined arms mode which sounds like a
cool alternative that's more of a co-op
it sounds like it sounds like it's there
like alternate answer to horde mode
almost you drop in you have one
objective you do it and you get out and
you don't have to complete it based on
the press kit that they sent out you
just have to you get points for your
company to put in the experience it
reminds me this is a very this isn't a
deep cub it's a weird comparison you
guys play hell jumpers few years ago
Helldivers yeah that was what you did it
was like a procedurally generated you
drop in this was the third person like
isometric overhead view but you drop
into an objective get out and you get
points based on what you like succeed in
it sounds like what they're doing
combined arms a little bit yeah that
sounds cool yeah random objectives like
make your own call like hey guys we are
out of ammo let's abort yes take what we
got so if they go according to schedule
EA will start in about three minutes
they are doing their own pre-show right
now so John Luke's in the back room he's
gonna tell me when they end that so we
might go a little bit into 11 o'clock
Pacific so I just want to talk about a
few more things before we get in there
we can talk about sports unraveled to
like leak they're purporting to be
released during the show right look
according to rumors and then there was a
photo you just showed us of it act like
a you know like a someone's playing I
love to friends the friends that I
pretend to have I want to talk about
yeah there was Madden we got few funds
we'll be there
Nick margarita is our sports expert he's
we're not he's doing production right
now but so but he was hoping he's
curious if like Madden continues with
their their longshot mode I believe it's
called which is their story because corn
da they took like four years to make
that story mode so we're wondering if
that's gonna be a yearly thing or if
they're without Alex hunter you actually
said Alex Jones I want I want them to
lean into the the crazy it starts again
I want him to lean into the extreme
sports stuff again I wish they'd bring
back stuff like lions on a field Lionel
Messi is an alien I have proof bring
back SSX tricky where's Alex Newhouse we
need em come during Ubisoft but that was
my boss deep they tweeted have an image
of stevia there's gonna be more steep
stuff for sure cool
do you expect much if any news in
relation to switch games from EA that
was from SM Molony I feel like the EA
originals like that kind of indeed
brands like fake a melon switch right
and if unravel to unravel seems like
yeah and the sports games will all be
there oh yeah yeah like FIFA will be
there's Mass Effect remastered trilogy
came to switch that would be remastered
dead space Mass Effect whoa
dead space swish sorry yeah that's good
aspect hell yeah oh wait guys a game
that I absolutely hundred percent want
to be announced at master snuggle
tweeted garden warfare 3 ok I'm sorry to
cut you all yeah is about to go wives
thanks for joining to the pre-show stick
around we're gonna talk about their
press conference after but EA is getting
ready to go live we're gonna go right
into that see you then
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
a little bit later in the show but
welcome everybody to EA play I'm Andrew
Rene and while you might recognize me
from the gaming community I'm kind of a
new face around here so this year EA
wanted to change things up because they
know that I'm both a gamer and a fan so
they invited me to come and host the
show and I think this year is gonna be a
lot of fun you guys I hope you're ready
because we're about to kick the
press-conference off but before we do
that EA play is more than just the show
you're about to watch right behind these
doors there is a fan fest outside and it
is huge this year it's a full 3d gaming
festival where thousands of gamers can
come and play games for free now inside
the theater here there are hundreds of
community members from all over the
world who are going to be capturing
streaming and getting their first
impressions of the games that we're
gonna be showing out here today but
before we can get to that we've got some
reveals of course we're gonna kick
things off with a look at battlefield 5
multiplayer now I know Trevor Noah gave
you the first look yeah we can clap it
up last month but we've got some new
stuff to show you today
then we're gonna move on to FIFA 19 and
boy do they have some big news you guys
any World Cup fans you guys excited
then we've got two new indie games to
share and then I'm gonna come back
towards the end of the show with some of
my favorite developers to give you guys
a nice meaty look at anthem and of
course yeah we got the Woo's for anthem
I'm into it you want it you wanna do
this with me well what did we find you
guys have I killed you all the secrets
at once right give him a break he needs
to just enjoy the show so without
further ado let's get things started
[Music]
[Applause]
right it's time to kick this thing off
it's been two weeks since I read a
battlefield 5 you know what it's been
exciting it's been a lot of speculation
and so many brilliant remixes of a
reveal trailer but there's also been
lots and lots of questions from the
community and we've heard you you want
to see more gameplay innovations you
want to know how customization actually
works and we want to know more about our
take on the Second World War so today
we'll show you more gameplay and what
this is the deepest and most immersive
battlefield yes it certainly is
you will be able to dive and smash
through windows to surprise your enemies
where previously defenses were
stationary you will now be able to move
these weapons around on the battlefield
and gain advantages in our renowned
destruction system is back and more
impactful than ever so well you can't
really hide from those pesky tanks and
more as they come chasing you for you as
they rip through those buildings and you
will now be able to customise your
soldiers your vehicles and your weapons
not only for the gameplay but for the
looks as part of our portrayal of the
Second World War
that's just the tip of the iceberg in
Belleview 5 you're going to see a lot
more of our new gameplay systems here at
EA play from our community so let's talk
about our single-player in war stories
yes let's do that so we want to tell you
about those untold stories that got us
excited to start with in this game it's
about what you will see is really those
moments of human heroism
it is about witnessing the world through
the eyes of the men and the women who
shaped the world forever real and real
and relatable people facing the
brutality of war we started off by a
exclusive look at the new lease war
story over at the Xbox briefing tomorrow
thanks that says something not to miss
tomorrow
so launching October is just the
beginning you will all go on an
expanding journey through a second world
war no loot boxes no premium pass every
day will bring something new and as part
of that journey after launch you'll get
something I know a lot of you have been
asking for mm-hmm
it's Royale
it's the Royal reimagined for
Battlefield so we bring those pillars of
battlefield with destruction team played
vehicles into this new experience so we
will bring your experience that you
haven't played before in battlefield or
anywhere else but more about that later
this year so with that it's time to show
you what makes battlefield so special
it's the unmatched intensity /
multiplayer sandbox and this time it's
even more epic fighting across multiple
maps and modes welcome to your next
battlefield experience and this is your
first look at ground operations at this
time even featuring music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
but you're in copper
[Music]
[Applause]
cuando era Crianza solution kind of nom
complain
ab c--'s determinism even that Vince
here
amazement immense manifestation to
change to continue our accreta
I start walking dad you two must resume
two ways a champion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's the UEFA Champions League the
pinnacle of club football were the
world's best clubs compete and icons of
the game like Gerard and Cruyff cemented
their legacies the world's biggest
league joins the world's game and a
special thanks to the legendary Hans
Zimmer and la zone Vince staples for
collaborating with us on the trailer and
I really love the trailer because it
captures our epic vision for how the
Champions League comes to life in FIFA
19 and Lina's going to tell you a little
bit more about that as Aaron said the
UEFA Champions League is an amazing
addition for the game it's where
football's biggest heroes like Ronaldo
and Neymar clash every year and it's the
place where champions rise and you've
been asking for this for a long time and
we are thrilled that it's here and
that's why we're bringing the Champions
League across the game will be an
authentic Champions League tournament
mode your club will chase this trophy in
career mode Alex hunter will pursue
Champions League glory in your story
mode the journey and in FIFA Ultimate
Team will be live and authentic
Champions League content and we'll share
more details on that along with all our
other Ultimate Team features later this
summer and all that's just the beginning
as you know the heart and soul of FIFA
is gameplay and this year we're giving
you the tools to control the pitch in
every moment from your tactical approach
to the match to each technical touch and
we know how passionate you are about
gameplay so we've worked hard to shape
and refine our vision for FIFA 19 with
input from our community from hands-on
tests with beginners to detailed
feedback sessions with FIFA pros and
we're gonna be sharing a lot more about
gameplay throughout the summer but what
I can tell you right now is that the
quality bar in gameplay was raised yet
again this year so we look forward to
everybody experiencing the game on the
hands-on sessions this week and also of
course we're extremely excited for
everybody to play it when we launch on
September 28th and that's our FIFA 19
news
headlined by the UEFA Champions League
but I just wanted to take a minute to
pause and reflect standing next to this
trophy is a little bit surreal you know
growing up there's two iconic trophies
that every young player dreams of
winning and for your club it's this one
the pursuit of Champions League glory
well for your country it's this trophy
the World Cup and with the tournament
starting in just five days we're excited
for the world to compete for it in FIFA
18 as you can imagine all of us on the
FIFA team can't wait for the start of
the World Cup and we want to celebrate
with FIFA 18 players which is why we've
just updated the game with a free World
Cup experience on PlayStation 4 Xbox one
ps3 and an intent to switch but you can
take Ronaldo on Portugal to the first
World Cup victory or you can write your
own story
with some great nations who didn't
qualify this year or you can make a
crazy dream a reality for your home
country like mine Iceland who would have
thought that the nation of only 350,000
people would ever qualify and you can
feel their excitement
apologies to any England fans in the
room I might still sting and Lina isn't
the only one who's excited
FIFA 18 players are loving the World Cup
experience so far but we don't want to
stop there we want to invite everyone to
come and join the celebration so I'm
pleased to announce that for a limited
time FIFA 18 complete with the entire
World Cup experience is available for a
free trial on PlayStation 4 and Xbox one
and on PC through Origen access yeah you
can download and play the entire game
right now for free
so to kick off the trial we've got some
of the world's biggest creators we're
gonna be playing live at the end of the
show representing their Nations in a
little mini World Cup tournament and
this summer will bring so much more for
FIFA fans plenty of FIFA 18 content
centered around World Cup and will bring
you all the details on FIFA 19 but in
the meantime let's all enjoy the World
Cup thank you and Travis Dunn
[Applause]
[Applause]
good morning EA SPORTS FIFA 19 you know
the FIFA community never rests 20
million people from 60 countries playing
in competitive leagues this year
well the FIFA team never rests either
bringing the Champions League and the
World Cup and so much other greatness to
fee for this year we can't wait for you
to experience at all we've got so much
to do here today but I want to welcome
you to EA play
it's our third ea play and our second
one in Hollywood and we couldn't be more
excited to have you with us to share all
the games that we have to show you we've
got lots to do but before we get before
we move on I'd like to share just a
couple of things the greys disruption to
the consumption of entertainment media
in the last five years is the
combination of streaming plus
subscription as consumers watching
movies watching TV listening to music
reading books has never been easier and
we believe that disruption is going to
be up have a profound impact on our
industry in the next few years and so
over the last couple of weeks you will
have seen that we announced a new team
from Israel has joined Electronic Arts
to help our investment to extend our
thinking and extend our pioneering into
this cloud gaming world for many people
that's gonna mean extending the
experiences they already play in our
partner platforms for others it's going
to mean new games and new modalities of
play across a whole variety of platforms
but for everyone it's gonna mean playing
games anywhere anytime so this week
we've got a tech demo running all of our
games streaming in HD from the cloud to
multiple devices do you bow to try out
for yourselves now it's not quite ready
for a full market primetime yet but it
is a promise of what we hope to bring
you in the future the second part of
that of course is subscription and we
started subscription a number of years
ago and many millions of you have signed
up and experienced the joy of being able
to have full access to a great catalog
of games today we're announcing origin
access
premiere so three things you need to
know about it
origin access premier will bring you all
of our new PC games starting with Madden
NFL back on the PC for the first time in
over a decade
then FIFA 19 battlefield 5 and of course
anthem and there'll be many more titles
in the years to come second you get
access to the vault our library of over
a hundred games from EA and other
publishers and third it will launch
later this summer so that's a little
later in the year but if you want to get
started right now and experience the
benefits and joys of subscription come
in and play a free trial of origin
access our base subscription this
weekend thank you and have a great show
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey everybody here what's up so I'm here
sitting inside the crowded EA play and I
just happened to find a mr. Vince
Zampella here in the audience Marie's
mine what's going on Vince how you
feeling today I'm feeling great I love
this stuff
I love seeing new games I mean someone's
super excited about that men on PC right
yeah so you guys may have seen that
Vince was tweeting yesterday and there
has been a bunch of speculation so you
want to just get right to it
sure I mean we're not ready to show all
of our stuff yet we're working on a
bunch of stuff it's amazing the teams
are kicking ass but we wanted to bring a
little tid bit so we've been working
with Lucas on getting the name and kind
of the setting for what our Star Wars
games gonna be em we're gonna talk about
it right now
oh you guys got any guesses I bet you
the Internet is going wild right now I
hope so so the Star Wars name is Jedi
fallen order so Star Wars Jedi fallen
order yeah so it kind of gives you some
idea that you'll be playing a ji so does
that mean I get to like hold a
lightsaber yes so Vince you got it got
anything else well it takes place during
the dark times trying to be a little
vague here but when the Jedi's are being
hunted so it's gonna be expect a Q ler
so for other like the hardcore nerds out
there who want to know like where in the
timeline like what between which
episodes is it between three and four
okay
I went right between three or four but
sounds like a nice time you got it eh
any other tidbits it's not a nice it's a
dark time it's a dark time bad time does
that mean this could just be all dark
and it's serious it's amazing
all right so I think people are now
anxiously want to know like what wedding
can we play the game it will be holiday
of next year 2019 not this year so sorry
it's a destiny hope yeah but now that we
know we can set expectations we're all
can have you amped up and hopefully
we'll hear from more from you maybe and
maybe next year oh yeah well Vince it
was great to see you thanks for stopping
by the show today we do have a little
bit more news on Star Wars so I'm gonna
toss it over to Dennis
hello there my name is Dennis I work at
dice in Stockholm on Star Wars
Battlefront 2 I'm really happy and
excited to be here today so thank you so
much for hanging out with me for a
little bit so we launched our games in
November of last year and clearly we
didn't get it quite right so instead of
coming out of the gate sprinting like we
really wanted to we had to take a step
back and make sure that we were
delivering the game that our players
really wanted so we decided to
completely overhaul our progression
system and add a bunch of new character
cosmetics for players to collect instead
so from there we added a new hunt mode
inspired by the original battlefront
games that I loved personally starting
with the Ewoks on Endor and thank you we
it turned out to be by far the most
popular update of the game and the team
loved building Ewok hunt so as you might
know we're currently in our Han Solo
season with content from the movie
coming next week it's headlined by the
new Planet Kessel's a really dangerous
place and it features the return of one
of our favorite modes extraction so
looking forward a little bit this summer
we will be introducing a new squad
system to the game which will allow you
to team up much easier and play with
your friends we're also adding a new
star fighter mode focused around
dogfighting which our hero ships and
looking ahead a little bit more we will
also be delivering a new large-scale
multiplayer sandbox experienced focused
around capturing command posts and
attacking and taking out capital ships
but that's not all
we know that you have been asking for
new heroes villains and planets from a
certain era that features a very iconic
Star Wars conflict so I'm excited to
confirm that battlefront 2 this year
we'll be going deep into the Clone Wars
[Music]
it's only fitting that we begin on the
planet Geonosis featuring multiple
levels including the largest level we
have ever built for battlefront so let's
talk about the heroes and villains first
let me introduce the most powerful droid
the leader of the most powerful droid
army in the galaxy general grievous and
yes he will be going up against my own
personal favorites Jedi Master obi-wan
Kenobi finally making its debut in
Battlefront after all these years so but
we're not done that's not it they will
not come alone joining them is the Dark
Lord and leader of the separatist
alliance Count Dooku as well as someone
to bring balance to the force
Obi Wan's unruly Padawan Anakin
Skywalker the team at home is extremely
excited to be building all of these cool
things EA and dice are committed to
battlefront we had a rough start but I
really think that this game has a bright
future thank you very much for playing
the game providing us with your feedback
talking to us together we will make this
as the greatest game that we can
possibly build there would be no
battlefront without you so thank you may
the force be with you and enjoy the rest
of a3 thanks
hi it's it's really good to see you in
arrival
we used yarn to symbolize love and the
bonds between people in our new game we
we tear that bond of right at the start
you lose everything including your spark
but when things are at their darkest you
find hope and you form a new bond and
your spark is rekindled and it leads you
off on an adventure so welcome to
unravel to
it's a game about fresh starts and
second chances these two little souls
who refused to give up and who build
something new and beautiful together and
the whole game is inspired by that
spirit of optimism and togetherness
you see it's all made to be played with
two characters you can play it alone or
you can play it in co-op with a friend
but there's always two characters
they're sharing one yarn and working
together to get through this adventure
this game it's quite different from the
first it's it's both friendlier and more
challenging but above all it's a lot
more playful and we think it's a worthy
successor and I want to show it to you
now so I brought some help so please
welcome Michael to the stage so I
producer out cold wood and we're gonna
try to show you a little bit of what I'm
talking about about how you can play the
game in co-op with yourself essentially
so when you're playing it by yourself
you can essentially pick up the other
character and carry them along through
the more fast-paced segments of the game
and we actually try to include a bit
more of those because we figured that
since it's a co-op game we wanted to
have more like thrill and danger and
kind of wild moments places that were
like fun and exciting
[Music]
and then when you get to the more
hustler areas like this when you're
problem solving
you can split apart into two and switch
back and forth between the two
characters because that's how we've
essentially designed all the problems
and puzzles of the game that you're
always working together and helping each
other out and utilizing this bond
between you to overcome any obstacle
that you come across
so I guess I'll jump in at this
community so I'm gonna be the red red
one okay I'll be blue a little
celebratory flip
[Music]
and the bird is back
putting it playing it safely now I'll
swing
I'll catch you
bat swing up okay you go
[Music]
okay this is the scary part it's a
freaking
got it
Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay I'll go up and distract the grouse
you can I'll sneak up here
[Music]
okay your turn yeah look at me keep him
over to the left now
now we can breathe again finally
[Laughter]
so that's a that's a quick little look
at unravel to
yeah I I really hope you like it and
before I go I just want to send some
some love to the team back home because
working on this game has been and a
completely amazing team effort in so
many levels and everybody has worked so
hard so there's there's a bunch of us
from cold wood here and thank you to
those and thank you to everybody back
home and thank you love you
[Applause]
[Music]
granduncle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Martin and the brilliant team
had called what the grade the game is
really strong these guys have done an
amazing job and it's clear that they
have a lot of passion and I can't
personally wait to play on rebel to with
my kids but what's even more amazing is
that we will make unravel to available
to everyone today yep you heard that
right
you'll be able to take these to your
knees on their next big adventure
starting today the game is finished it's
out so Thank You Martin and thank you
the team at Thole back in 2015 we
started in this journey with the
original unravel to seek out the most
creative independent developers and
bring them into our EA originals program
it's been our way of helping these
traders bring their unique games to the
world and to tell their stories and last
year if you remember Joseph Aras was up
here on stage representing his team at
Hays lights and the way out and I think
we all kind of remember that and you
might even remember him from the game
Awards as well I think I did anyhow in
March that game caught fire it's it was
in it its innovative it's fun and it's
something fresh and new and you all
loved it we saw over 2 million players
in the first two weeks and a way out is
such a huge success that Joseph and his
team are expanding and moving into a new
studio so stories like this drive our
industry and it's why we will continue
to work with independent developers to
help them realize their dreams which
leads us to our next year originals
title from a little game studio in
Berlin called Joe my games when I met
this team and I saw the game I was
instantly drawn to a personal this story
was it's one that tower carries a very
powerful and important message and it's
unlike anything we have ever done so
please welcome Connie capper to the
stage from Joe my games to tell you more
about Sea of Solitude
[Applause]
Thank You Patrick
I still remember during the pitch how
enthusiastic Pappy was and that
afterwards like our whole team including
me we're super excited it actually feels
a little bit the same right now I am
pretty excited
maybe a little too excited
we are you my small indie game studio
from Berlin and we are developing sea of
solitude or SOS as we call it the whole
journey from the very first concept to
actually becoming a part of EA original
is simply amazing let me tell you more
about our game when humans get too
lonely they turn into monsters this is
at the core of everything you will see
here and hopefully feel while playing
SOS what makes this underlying concept
so important and so unique asset nearly
every human being can at least somehow
relate to all remember the feeling of
being lonely in my case I started
writing the story when I fed solonius in
my life I think as an artist you
processed your emotional word by letting
it out and putting it into your art I'm
still amazed how like the concept seems
to just float out of me like right into
the hand and onto the paper I think this
is also why so many people can instantly
connect this again because it's not a
made-up story
even though
that it takes place in a fantastic
setting in SOS we try to show how people
experience different kinds of loneliness
but also how Outsiders friends and
family see those who struggle we achieve
others and playful ways so that players
who wants to simply enjoy a fantastic
experience can do so but player who
wants to look a bit deeper can reveal a
whole emotional world beneath it or CF
solitude is about a young woman named
Kay who is suffering from such strong
loneliness at her inner feeling the
darkness the anger the hopelessness
worthlessness turns to the outside and
she becomes a monster the game is about
finding out why is this happened to her
but also how to turn her back into a
human what he made Lea the goal is to
bring all those emotions into balance
some needs to become bigger some would
be better a little smaller but to
embrace even your destructive part or
your self-doubt in the same way you
embrace your joy or your hope this is
what being human is all about and that's
what our game is all about thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
this world I live in is empty and I know
child destiny and no fortune son just
chased you so long today is here
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah I'm the one but I'm not the only
one we are the one we can set you down
and we can put you or not crossover
Gavin
[Music]
trust the process
[Applause]
and this is mah squad
[Applause]
my name is Sheikh Evelyn aka young kid
I'm from Seattle Washington the only
goal of mine is really to it's a big
night for young kids he's been stuck at
the quarterfinals and here he is now in
his first championship looking to
accomplish a goal
34 throws at love
and trainees got the lead 42:19 eat
using way more than I love women we have
a credible matchup it's a rematch
you wanna get smacked
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how you doing I've been good
you saw a cover from that butt whuppin
Wow already hey hi everybody I'm juju
Smith Schuester from the Pittsburgh
Steelers as you guys can see King up
touchdown celebrations
that's pretty far I like that a lot
as you guys know this is junk if madding
18 Madden champions like give it up
young young kid
how has it been you know your success in
your past you know to where you're at
today it's I've always been a competitor
when I was in high school I was playing
baseball I hurt my arm so then I picked
up Madden and at first I was really bad
I was getting blown out online but I
kept at it I put more and more time into
it eventually I made my first tournament
but I had a big decision that was the
same time as my graduation Wow okay so
the key to be the number one player in
magnets to hurt your arm in baseball
number two
you said you had the decision to be to
go to your graduation or go to a
tournament so like what did you do
I chased that money I still got my
diploma but I chased that money that's
awesome okay now the past two you know
the past few years how has it been for
you I know you had some ups and downs
it's been tough I've had a lot of
devastating losses I've been so close so
many times I made the final on TV and
got blown out of all those losses and
made me gain a lot of mental toughness
and that's why I got this belt that's
awesome that belt is so amazing there's
a lot of you know bling on that belt for
you well today EA play you know first
look at the Madden my team trailer super
excited it's gonna be so fun it's lit I
honestly wish I can stare and talk to
you guys forever well I'm not gonna
bored you guys we're gonna go out I'm
gonna try and take this belt you know
round two so we're out help your day
[Applause]
you've worked your whole life to get to
moments like these to the very top of
the mountain
[Applause]
failure oh just to get to this place
where you've been told legends are born
[Applause]
you fall so you can rise and you rise so
that you can truly see see that it was
really never about reaching the end of
the road at all but about all the
moments that got you here
[Music]
their position the truth at the moment
to find you or will you define the
moment
[Applause]
[Music]
hello ladies john i'm Nathania special
shoutcaster here alongside redwood
studios general manager Michael Martinez
how you doing today I'm super excited to
be here yeah we're gonna do this
presentation a little bit differently
and give you your first look at a brand
new mobile game in a live
winner-take-all head-to-head match
Michael let's tell us the rules sure
thing
the objective is straightforward
destroyed the opponent's base to win
unit control super simple just tap it
tap to destination unit automatically
moves they're the most efficient way to
destroy the opponent's base is with this
giant nuclear missile in the center of
the map control the missile by standing
on a majority of the control points a
bar fills up while the missiles
possessed whoever controls the missile
when the bar fills up will fire the
missile takes two missiles to destroy
the enemy's base and win that's it
sounds great Michael well enough talking
about it let's let's get to this match
absolutely all right ladies and
gentlemen we have an awesome matchup
lined up for you here today fighting for
the blue side of the room if you could
please give a cheer for one of the most
formidable RTS players there is make
some noise for in control
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
his opponents fighting for the red side
of the room a competitive mobile gaming
phenomenon please join me in welcoming
to the stage Nick at Nite
[Applause]
now Mike it's gonna be a real clash of
these gaming sounds the competitive
backgrounds that these players have it
should be a great lunch it really is I
can't wait all right are the players
ready let's get this thing going ready
to go I'm ready to go let's do it all
right let's kick this off a nice little
strategy game yes you out there it's a
good John Rowe I'm very excited for this
the players are loading in and we are
ready to the match here we go
aah as the players bases have been
deployed and the action begins like any
strategy game economy will be the focus
with a harvester to start things off
nothing too crazy nothing too crazy
now the infantry is gonna come out to
hold that top point both players of
course trying to take that position Nick
and Knight being able to reach it a
little bit first in a strategy game that
flank position that in control is going
from the top side also very important as
Nick at Knights forces have to circle
around the center right let's see if
he's able to create a two-on-one is he
able to get there he's getting there
here comes GI with uh with rhino it's
gonna rip up those infantry yeah going
for the anti infantry and like any
strategy game the units that you're
going to use when you deploy them will
have a huge impact your micromanagement
of your forces and protecting that
economy is you know make a night with
some attack bikes in the top there he is
in control placing the turret on the top
right side to help cover that Rhino as
attack bikes move towards the northwest
position can see that the missile is
beginning to ready and firing that that
takes out half your base the most
important objective on the map is to
hold those control zones right and in
control making a lot of progress to that
far right side of the match it's done a
great job of pulling that down with the
turret and now he's redeploy these
vehicles from the south side bringing
out more infantry to deal with the
attack bikes and as the economy ramps up
of course we've seen bigger more
powerful units come out we have there
the drill pod coming in the left side to
help in putting those some doors right
absolutely again those are gonna tear
through those infantry yeah and in
control brings out his first tank that's
gonna be used to trying to help push
back these smaller forces as he makes
his way to the south side that missile
passing halfway now to control of Nick
at night he will have the missiles we
see it starts to point towards in
control space let's see if in control
can get around to that top corner able
to hold that missile he does contestant
missile put it into yellow position now
very important of course blocking the
the pathing of those units is another
big factor for the strategy holding
those locations is so crucial as in
control begins to secure the northwest
spot another tapes gonna come out from
Nick it nice to take it out but now he's
bringing up and pitbull as well to help
lock down that North this missile is
very very close to firing let's see
what's gonna happen with another turret
and control blinks he takes the top that
missile and then Wow and Nick at night
one shot away from being knocked out
here as the next one will start sit
ready up in just a moment
timing controls very heavy artillery
force they're doing a great job at
taking control of the map doubles you
can see as more of Nick and nice forces
move up towards that north position
those harvesters of course very crucial
very important to protect those as your
economy allows you to get these big
late-game units the units are gonna come
out of it more slowly as you get more of
them on the field but in control just
spreading it's worse is out trying to
hold this advantage that he's had so far
Nick at night is trying to get in there
but there's a great turret placement
from in control blocking and just
ripping through again those infantry and
we see in control now moving in tank
boards there's other drill powders in
with some flame tanks yeah bringing the
flag of course let's play guys do
amazing damage to the infantry help to
clean that out meanwhile two more tanks
coming out from Nick at night to try and
secure those positions he brings up the
laser infantry on the south side is
going for counters trying to
scout out and see what your opponent is
doing and make the proper response is so
important in strata up salutely Nick a
knife cruising around thinking about
harassing those harvesters coming around
the far side for those rhinos it looks
like he's really pressing it you see
that missile is starting to get close to
five with three zones and control for
Nick and Knight looking to set things
back the other way in control trying to
rally his force really doesn't want to
engage with just one or two units he
wants to move all of them together
create a good flank position and take
over that sours in the first mech units
from in control this is the Wolverine
gonna rip them this close watch out
through this missile and Nick in there
go for next missile is gonna end X
missile wedge see what happens we'll
have control of Wolverines as you
pointed out for any control coming out
and trying to deal with these forces but
Nick ignites and a great job of getting
that presence and now also harassing the
economy yep Wow okay we've got our first
mammoth tank on the board it's Nick the
big control can get this in position is
gonna do some serious damage that
missile just passed halfway ready he's
also bringing out his first air unit wow
deal with there's a lot going on here
it's got a lot of range that big boy and
in control just need some this missile
is nearly gonna fire it could be super
done where's it gonna go is he gonna be
able to get it off
amazing thank you I just came to make
mammoth tanks so I've done my job yeah
absolutely
a little bit everything right there
perfect yeah let's hear it for our
Nathaniel Nick at night and in control
ladies and gentlemen what you just saw
was the worldwide reveal of command &
Conquer rivals rivals reimagines the
realtime strategy experience for mobile
we're giving players complete continuous
control of their armies in quick
competitive head-to-head matches that
are fueled by skill and strategy now
rivals will be coming to iOS and Android
devices but I'm excited to announce that
Android players can play the pre-alpha
today so head to the Google Play Store
search command & Conquer rivals the
studio has been having an absolute blast
playing this game and we can't wait for
you to play please let us know what you
think thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
command & Conquer for a new generation
now before we close the show with a
spectacular epic anthem I wanted to
share a few final things I am blessed to
be able to work with some of the most
creative people on the planet who come
to work every day to create amazing
entertainment and what I can say about
all of those teams and we can say about
us
is that we are always trying to learn
and listen and strive to be better and
so as you look at the 10 experiences
that you're going to see today and as
you play games this week there's some
things we hope come through first that
at the very core is choice is that you
as players get to choose how you play
what you play when you play and what
devices you play on that in making those
choices you feel you are treated fairly
that no one is given an unfair advantage
or disadvantage for how they choose to
play that for every moment that you
invest we know that you put so much of
your life into the games we make and
that for every moment you invest you
feel like you are rewarded and you were
given value for that investment and most
importantly that the games are fun that
we move past the grind and that these
are experiences that truly enhance your
lives and so as we think through all the
things that we're trying to do know that
we want to be better and that we want to
make great games and that as much as we
love making games and as much as you
love playing them there's something that
is even greater that we can do together
the power of this community when we come
together to do amazing things is
profound last weekend was the third year
of our play to give program where we
show the world how the power of play can
be a positive force for social impact
millions of you out there participated
in nine in game challenges in our games
loking millions of hours in support of
play to give and to celebrate that we
contributed a total of 1 million
two three charities that share our
vision for a more inclusive world a
world where representation and equality
are not something we strive for
they are the standards and where
bullying and exclusion are not an
everyday thread these three
organizations the United Nations he for
she paces National Bullying Prevention
Center and ditch the label an
anti-bullying organization all are doing
great work and we're proud to support
them through Play to give back and thank
you for your support
thousands of us at EA and millions of
you together doing immeasurable good
because we love games thanks for being
with us and thanks for the incredible
privilege of making games for all of you
now without further ado let's take a
look at anthem the gods
vanished
and left our world and chaos creating
altering destroying the anthem is all
that remains
there's a storm coming these walls can
protect us forever
it wants to destroy us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how cool was that tremor you guys I've
seen it a couple times and it's so cool
every time I see it so I know all of you
like me have had tons of questions about
anthem since last year because we're all
by our fans so we're gonna do something
a little bit different for the rest of
the show and we're gonna take a deep
dive into anthem so I'm gonna bring out
some members of the bio team to chat
with us ladies and gentlemen please give
a warm welcome to Casey Hudson Marc Dara
and Kathleen roots are
[Applause]
[Music]
all right thanks guys thanks for coming
out today it's gonna be very exciting so
Casey we're gonna go ahead and just jump
right in and get started with you so now
we know that you all started or case you
started your career at Bioware way back
in the day but you took a couple years
off but before you came back you
actually worked on anthem before you
left yeah that's right so you know first
of all it's amazing to be back it's
awesome to be making games for Bioware
fans you know we have the best fans so
it's been super satisfying to come back
to it and you know I just want to be
able to continue the legacy of the
studio and that's kind of where it
started with anthem is just thinking
about you know what is the evolution of
a Bioware game and we wanted to create a
brand new world for people to discover
you know a whole new world of story and
character but we also wanted to do
something that was you know more of a
dynamic and living world in the game
that would change every time you came
back and played it we also wanted to do
something where you know if you wanted
to invite your friends into it then you
could do that as well so that was really
the initial vision of the game not an
MMO not a multiplayer game with story
sort of bolted on this side but
something new and different and I think
the team has really captured that vision
over the years your fans really love the
stories from Bioware but I think we're
kind of curious how you're planning to
make story work in this shared world so
a great story for Bioware is really
about characters that you can have a
connection with choices you get to make
and feeling like the stories about you
in a lot of multiplayer games those
things get diluted because you're mixing
multiplayer and storytelling into the
same areas now you can build a solution
to that but you have to really build it
into the core of the game and that's
what we've tried to do with with anthem
so what we call our world my story so
when you're out in the open world the
world is really dangerous and you're
focused on your mission and this is
where other players get to play with you
the thing that's really interesting
about this it's unique for for
is that this is a living shared world so
whether there's weather or it's
nighttime what we're experiencing we're
experienced together everyone that's
plain anthem in at a moment is seeing
the same thing and this is what we mean
when we talk about our world it's a
shared world that we all experience
together but then when I finished my
mission I come back to a base like for
Tarsus and this is a single-player
experience I turn in my my rewards I
talked to some characters I experienced
the choices of my action and this is
where your story really lives and breeze
and by doing it this way we were able to
combine that impact an agency of a
single player story with the fun of
teaming up with your friends to play
co-op in combat and we're also designing
it so that we can add story for years to
come so one of the first things that we
hear when from our community is they
want to continue to play in our worlds
when they finished Mass Effect or Dragon
Age players want more story and so we've
designed anthem in a way that we can
actually add more story for years to
come and it could be anything a new
moment with a character that you've
grown to love or event in the world that
deep into the lore or an entirely new
storyline and plot well I'm certainly
not gonna complain about more story and
I'll take anybody house there's going to
either soak up I mean I wanted to ask
you from a writing perspective since you
are the lead writer can you speak to
what it's like to create a new world
like anthem from the beginning well
what's really exciting for us and not
just the writers but all of the the devs
the designers the artists is that we're
creating something new and mysterious
for players to discover so at the heart
of the premise of anthem is a world left
unfinished by the gods but the gods left
behind their massive tools and those
tools are in constant conflict with this
unknowable force called the anthem of
and the chaos of those things pushing
against each other means that the world
is constantly being reshaped in new and
unpredictable ways yeah violent storms
mutant creatures gigantic monsters it's
a dangerous environment that you need to
wear a suit of power armor a javelin -
to be safe and now something I think a
lot of players out there maybe don't
stop to think about is just how much
work goes into creating a new
intellectual property or IP as we've
been saying now you know we've seen all
these different creatures and Mark you
mentioned the storms what's the process
of creating a game like from scratch
yeah it's something we've done a few
times at Bioware you know and really the
hardest part is getting started just
kind of getting off the blank page so
what we tried to do is we think about
the new experiences that we're trying to
unlock for players so like what is the
fantasy fulfillment what are the new
things you actually get to go and do
that are different from what you've
played before so that's where we start
and then once we think about those
things you know that's the power of
creating new IP especially for games is
that you actually get to build a whole
fictional universe that's meant to bring
out a certain experience and then once
we do that then we kind of we still need
to build all the rest of the stuff and
what unlocks us creatively is to think
about like principles around art style
tone and even the technology in the
politics of our new world and then from
there we can actually go and build out
every last detail yeah and one of the
unique challenges for anthem is that
it's a world and experience that's meant
to feel alive like it's happening right
now
and so the world is always changing
weather the storms seasons and yeah it's
a really great concept to write for
because what it means is it gives us the
opportunity to drop into the world
almost in real time a dramatic event
that changes the world for everyone and
that could be anything from game play to
lure many of them all of the moving
parts in the dynamic world sound really
cool the way that they sound like
they're gonna come together but even
though there's obviously a lot going on
it really
back to your character so let's talk
about who we're gonna be playing as and
why we're fighting these crazy piece so
you are a freelancer uniquely skilled to
pilot these EXO jet these javelin
exosuits
and you need those suits to survive and
fight in this world because the world
will kill you but on top of that our
ancient rivals the Dominion have they
discovered a way they think to weaponize
the anthem of creation and so we need to
stop them and protect the free people of
tarsus no power armor a couple different
things is it a suit is it a javelin like
what's the what's the cannon term here
we call them javelins and there are four
and they each have unique abilities
there's the Ranger and then there's the
Colossus the Interceptor and finally the
storm yeah so each javelin gives you a
different way to play the game but the
thing to remember is like Kathleen said
you're not your suit you are freelance
or a pilot which means you can decide
which suits you want to use based on
your mood based on the mission you want
to engage it or the use or the javelins
that your friends are using so really
what this allows us to do is we've built
the suits to look like they're built
from the materials of the world so they
each have their own unique abilities
let's take a look at the Ranger now the
Ranger is a more generalized suit able
to do a lot of different things but use
really designed for up close and
personal combat one on one for the most
part the Colossus is heavier more
specialized but able take really in big
weapons that let them data state the
battlefield
I'm just gonna say this storm looks like
it's gonna be my favorite I'm sure you
guys are taking your faves right now -
so the javelins awesome but we're gonna
take a couple questions right now so
Casey tweeted some of you may have seen
asking for people out there to send us
your questions and the first one is
gonna be from out it's sweet Nicole who
asks as a player who is all about making
their character their own what kind of
customization options will be available
in anthem yeah so we really want players
to express himself both through
customizing the way their their javelin
plays through gear and weapons but also
being able to personalize the way that
it looks both through paint jobs as well
as changing the actual geometry of the
suit itself we want teams to be able to
do this as well and because you're going
to be using a javelin for a long period
of time we really want you to be able to
make it your own
I'm glad you brought that up because
actually a Jail Aikido has a question
connected to customization monetization
how when loop box cosmetics yeah so we
are going to have some cosmetics and
vanity items that you'll be able to
purchase but you're always going to know
what you're gonna buy before you spend
any money on it so no loot boxes no
ability to pay for power so that means
no ability to spend money on game play
advantage at all with an anthem but even
more important that we want to make sure
that anthem is an immersive experience
that feels like it's complete from the
get-go so that means a main story a big
open world and an ongoing service that
provides new content for a long period
of time new story new new new
experiences for everyone well I'm glad
to hear that I can make my javelin pink
that's really all I want to know I'm
gonna be honest all right Casey we
talked earlier about this being a co-op
experience so can you tell me a little
bit about how the team game plan anthem
is gonna work yeah it really is about
you know the fun of teaming up as as a
team of superheroes and working together
so you want to get a few people together
of different classes so you know I think
here we're gonna see the the Colossus
you know just hammering people on the
ground in gameplay we can have a look at
that so heavy artillery being released
you know in melee combat and then here
you've got the Ranger shooting down from
above and then they're using comms and
your combos and special abilities and
stuff like that but what I love is you
don't just run around you're swimming
and flying as well so it's interesting
because at the sweet tones wants to know
how will you balance multiplayer with
single-player storytelling
so anthems really built around trying to
combine the the impact of having your
own personal story with the fun of
playing with other players but we really
want to make sure that that playing with
other people feels like a choice so for
people that want to just experience the
story we you're gonna be able to do that
now going out into an open world like
this by yourself is going to be a little
bit more challenging than than if the
team of four people and we've really
tried to balance the coop experience to
be fun even for people that don't
normally engage in this kind of thing so
I really hope that everyone at least
gives co-op a try okay that's good to
know if you want a role solo you can but
more difficult well I know you all are
on the edges of your seats how about we
show a little gameplay yeah all right so
I'm Kevin I think you're gonna set this
up for us I will
so the your you and your friends have
decided to play a mission called scars
and villainy the scars have put together
an acid-based super weapon so you got to
take them out so you start in the
Strider which is like a giant Walker and
it's your forward base of operations you
have a conversation with your crew
palek FEI and owen and you'll hear owen
he's going to talk us through the
mission as we as we experience it here
and yeah then you just get into your
javelins suit and you head out with your
friends all right well thank you so much
mark Casey Kathleen for talking to me
about anthem today we're gonna go ahead
and roll the gameplay now enjoy
everybody
[Applause]
freelancer time to get to work they said
these bastards made some kind of acid
using it as a weapon
so find where they're making this
garbage and shut it all down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
owen what's the plan here yeah loads of
scars nearby take a look around the area
but sir be careful
right checking out the Skycam some more
look at all the women so are there other
turrets that move quickly
[Music]
there's a shaker on it wait something's
Falls get it closer look would you see
those radiant pieces of energy there
echoes from the anthem of creation loads
of scars nearby be careful
return them to the relic you've got to
silence it fast
it's got silence disaster overseas do
you think we get a bonus for wait
something's happening what the hell was
that I think that was whatever laid all
the eggs around here the sound came from
below your position
on the plus side this definitely council
would hazard pay there's a trainer this
acid gunk leading down follow it we
should find the source
[Music]
yep and that was that was actually just
a short version of the full demo that we
brought here to LA so if you want to
come by the Anthem theater here at EA
play you can check out the game lodge so
I'm sure the question on everyone's
minds when do we get to play so anthem
comes out February 22nd 2019 on Xbox one
Playstation 4 and PC the mark your
calendars everybody fire up your tweets
thank you so much again to keep the
entire Bioware team I know you guys have
that awesome theater outside so I will
see you guys there right I also want to
give a big thank you to all of the
developers who showcase their games
today and everybody working hard at
their Studios back home around the world
let's give them all a round of applause
now some of what you saw today you guys
have to wait to play but you guys EA has
so much available right now now for
those of you keeping score you can get
your free trial of FIFA 18th World Cup
today and Android told us about the free
trial of origin access yarny is back
with a buddy in unravel 2 which is also
available today plus you can take on
your friends in command and conquer
rivals starting today as well now a lot
available stuff that's out today's
anybody you ready to go home and
download anything no you're like I just
want to go outside to the fan fest I get
it I get it so I want to let you guys
know to keep your streams going because
in just a few moments the FIFA 18 World
Cup live tournament is going to begin
I'm gonna head outside and check out the
games but I want to thank everybody for
coming down to EA play today and
watching the press conference and have a
great weekend
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of été 3 2018 we just watched
the EA press conference a lot to take in
kind of not a lot to take in
anthem looks pretty sick I'm Mike
McCarty here with Lucy James hello Rob
Henry hello and tomorrow saying I hate
racing money that FIFA stream that
they're doing right now if you feel like
you really want to watch FIFA don't
leave our stream stay here we have seen
more from EA we got a release date for
anthem if every 22nd of next year
finally good white like how many 8
months I can't think right now
I can't maths right now yeah but that
game looks awesome I'm sure from the top
yeah well start with anthem wait let's
start with the shout out to if you
wouldn't get some questions in I will be
manning the Twitter feed please tweet us
using the hashtag GameSpot e3 and will
read out your questions comments
concerns about what you've just seen all
of your cries for where the hell was
skate for anthem they showed a little
more of all four rigs the classes that
we'll be playing as Casey Hudson was
there
mark Daraa was there Kathleen the writer
of Mass Effect Andromeda and this game
looks cool they seemed a little bit
annoyed that it was mostly a QA but Q
and a but they showed some gameplay they
showed a lot or the end what they showed
the Colossus was the one they showed a
lot that rig it'll be a world that you
could play solo or co-op although mark
taro said he hopes you play co-op but
that's kind of those are kind of just
buzzwords for all kinds of games like
this I would imagine reassuringly they
mentioned story a few times yeah
which was good Kathleen was on stage she
is obviously the writer and they kind of
laid the foundations of what's going on
the gods have left and you know
creations a bit weird
they don't clarify yeah then it sounds
like it was the force kind of like magic
energy creation yeah just gonna vent
right or something
it's something nebulous and
incomprehensible that will kind of
string the story along well I'm
interested in seeing how how you know
how they build out quests and that kind
of stuff the stuff that we show during
the gameplay demo at the end was very
much kind of standard fare for a demo
which is like oh we're gonna go over
here and do this thing over there and
the kind of the flavor text that was
supporting that was very I mean like the
stuff that we really want is the stuff
that we know Bioware for you know the
world building and that kind of stuff
and they didn't quite show how they're
gonna approach that but they did say in
a very cool way Kathleen was saying that
they were building the game so that they
could add new story content for years to
come hopefully like oh it's a new it's a
new DLC so it's gonna be a new area that
you can only that all just sounds like
buzzwords Furley updates but she was you
mentioned like quite granular changes
like the way you interact with a
character could change so that made me
think oh it's just like they want to
have the ability to change the world in
small and big ways in a way then you
know you keep coming back to destiny and
everyone says the same thing over and
over again and eventually you know
exactly what you need to do you can see
almost two now so I think they want to
it seemed like they were implying that
oh you want to pay attention every time
you're here because this character that
you might always speak to could change
like very slightly or give you a little
more flavor text again like Mike said
that could just be what buzzwords yeah
and like saying you know things oh who
knows how they'll be implemented but I
believe it when I see it but I am
optimistic you're just the gameplay
alone this flying like I saw people on
Twitter saying some of the devs saying
that there's an it's like a team
dedicated to the flying in the game they
showed I think they were running with
two colossi it looked like in this
gameplay I don't think I saw an
interceptor in this demo there was at
one point and they have shown that the
others they kind of show it off a lot of
like air mobility barrel rolls air
combat
zipping from side to side yeah that was
really cool yeah I guess you can imagine
the Interceptor being the more mobile
right like a road I I dug that I I
didn't expect to see like air combat as
much cuz before it was just a traversal
or and you know last e3 they just shut
it off as like getting a to B but that
was pretty cool
yeah they look so rickety in a way you
know like just barely and yeah it's nice
so a few people on the tweets are asking
an AK I'm just got Jonathan's asking do
you think that will add a PvP aspect to
you Anthony I feel like they're like
yeah they're going to manage to fit it
into Mass Effect they fit it into dragon
age again like the really bad yeah that
was PV but I feel like that's just a
logical step forward for them yeah
especially when you're building out
customization to be as a big part of the
game as it is you want some way to kind
of show that off beyond just a small
group of people and and you know kind of
pit your rig against someone else the
javelins yeah they sure look great
yeah they well they went through a whole
bunch of like skins and stuff but
there's totally like an all-black and
that's a good segue monetization they
said it's all gonna be there's gonna be
no random crates you're gonna know what
you're buying there's gonna be cosmetics
you can buy but outside of that they
said it's not gonna be pay to win and
that seems like a focus of the whole
conference I mean from Battlefront to
been listening some time away from
battlefront battlefront could have been
the best thing to happen for
microtransactions in a long time like
[Music]
just back in a way so fast no sounds
good I mean I seems like I would imagine
Bioware wouldn't implement that stuff
but being under EA who knows but it
sounds like they're being very cognizant
across the developers under EA that that
is bad press and they don't want to do
that yeah and they especially don't want
to take that gamble with a game like
anthem given that they committed so much
to it already and if it's supposed to be
like destiny it could be like the
cornerstone kind of like the pillar of
their business going forward they want
this game to be the game that people
we'll stick with for many many years so
if they if they don't like they need to
have the zero friction for people to get
into it like long it's been in
development as well so if KC was working
on it
then he left for like two years to go to
Microsoft and then he came back like
this time last year that's at least you
know four or five years exactly again
they cannot take a risk with with it and
change like they need to be so careful
with perception of the game and the
discussion around the game which means
that stuff like micro transactions they
don't want to know yeah I mean anthem I
think was a standout for the show mainly
the show game play they focus a lot on
it it was like one of the bigger tier
Triple A games let's talk about
battlefield unless there are any other
questions on Twitter about anthem image
I mean there's a lot of people asking
why we didn't see anything from Dragon
Age but I think it's one of those cases
where if by we're are gonna go hard on
anthem they're not gonna split their
audience you would say and do Dragon Age
as well there have been like tweets and
stuff about people working on Dragon Age
I'm certain it's gonna happen but this
year is they have committed to Dragon
Age they said it's not done yet so it's
just it's just a matter of anthem ease
and the flavor of the world for them
so as now February 22nd of 2019 you'll
be able to play anthem maybe a few days
early if there's EA plays stuff yeah
five days ahead of time sometimes like a
week okay well I'm excited I mean I said
before that's one of the games I was
rooting for people will seem annoying
there was a QA but they showed gameplay
right after it's also people I respect
Casey Hudson I mean
but anyway battlefield 5 probably the
next biggest they showed they showed a
little bit it was pretty so they
announced first off battlefield 5 will
have battle royale mode take the battle
all-out battle but like if you're saying
let's play some you little battlefields
royale like they're not calling
battlefield Rail it's over ala mode but
to distinguish it from for Knight and
other stuff I'd say battlefield Royale
with battle yes or cheese they announced
that but then they showed gameplay which
at first of a few people really Oh
this looks like the battlefield the
battle royale mode goddamnit
so it's so hard to just point and say
this is gameplay cuz this is well know
they said if they said before this that
it's captured an engine yeah then they
also it's they said like we're gonna
show new I don't know like I thought it
was the war stories at first but I
believe this is actually like the Grand
Operations mode were after that's right
which is the more objective based kind
of progressed progressive multiplayer
mode so yeah there's the building there
this is Norway sweet mechanic there with
the attaching of like flak cannons to
vehicles that's gonna be fun again stuff
like the new movement abilities a lot of
the granula T's like I just saw a guy
like sliding and shooting at the same
time like going back it's done yeah and
even more with animations they showed
off like the aesthetics too that we
heard about from Aaron when you did the
behind closed doors like the like raised
knees and like Shaolin like stumbling in
snow and stuff like I look pretty yeah
so Aaron was saying if you look at
someone running into a wall at like full
speed like running to cover they'll slam
into the wall or like you just mention
the high knees or presumably you know
like in deep mud maybe but from your
point of view you won't notice as much
but other people see it which seems like
it's a weird thing to balance but it
makes it look much better especially
like obviously the frostbite engine is
unreal looking already that was all the
gameplay the show today was in Norway
yeah yeah my god when he's british
commandos a very feature-rich game from
what we've seen so there's a lot of like
very different modes coming I mean the
the Royal thing is they said late their
talk more about it later this year which
could I mean the game it's unclear
whether games gonna launch with it or
whether it's gonna be like hey the games
out now now we're gonna start talking
about the royale mode yeah but at the
very least they have commit to it which
is something that wasn't confirmed
before this got rid of the premium pass
so yeah I would assume that it would
come you wouldn't have to pay yeah
so they got the Royal they've got grand
operations oh my god
war stories conquests they probably have
like an air focus mode then they have
well Battlefront 200 sometimes that will
they bind arms the control they can roll
some some of stuff out later like they
did without one like the whole you know
the Air Assault where it was called in
that day yeah that was a thing with one
the last DLCs for that game but yeah it
looked really great like there was some
cool stuff jacket the jacket absolutely
incredible jacket sell that EA old by
that yeah yeah for sure as well
oh there's one really cool moment it's
just you know that frostbite looks so
good like where they run into the
building and like snow of the house yeah
really making you to that frostbite
engine yeah like they are getting their
money's worth out of it it's an
expensive engine yeah I mean like and to
roll it out anthem showed it like on its
on a scale that we've not seen before
like battlefield is showing it off the
destruction seems to look better than
ever yeah it's exciting and you can
build you can build you can to tear down
a wall and put some sandbags up yeah and
then you can actually like the squad so
cuz they're bringing squads to
battlefront 2 as well but in battlefield
5 apparently squads can heal the other
members of their squads and then medic
specifically can heal and quicker and it
improve their health from what I've
heard right the idea is there's even
some kind of mechanic we didn't
obviously see it but like anyone can
heal just takes longer for anyone who's
not a medic right yeah if if you were
down knowing that I am NOT a medic it's
gonna take a long time yeah stick some
more apparently you can drag people who
are down like if we have do we have any
battlefield 5 questions that popped up
because otherwise we can go to no but
time later katie is actually gonna call
the royal mode
battlefield with chief so we've we've
done our job today yeah yeah do you want
to talk about I mean the big surprise
was sea of solitude man assaulted yeah
cool
Joe may the studio trans man yeah and
which is you know so this was they did
the unravel to reveal we talked a little
bit about that yeah it's available now
and co-op income it looked adorable but
honestly I got really excited about CLG
yeah yeah
a great idea looks beautiful looks very
melancholy I'm still unclear on what you
do yeah there's a lot of different
styles of like traditional how we think
about gameplay frameworks and that kind
of stuff like it looks like a bunch of
different game genres the mashed into
one like this puzzle solving from the
atmospheric stuff reminded me of inside
that moment and it reminded me of like
the fact that she spent firstly she
absolutely nailed that speech talking
about loneliness and you could tell it
was very personal to her not in a way
that it was like this is a game that I'm
working on the same way that like you
know the guys from unravel did last year
and this made a conquer yeah whole thing
came about when it was a deeply personal
moment from you know is born from my
loneliness yeah and it explores that so
the fact that it kind of we can't really
get a grip on it is really interesting
because it's a personal thing like that
journey is it's the manifestation of her
journey and for us to kind of if we
immediately be able to say like I said
this kind of game that game it would be
a bit like it water that down somewhat
so the fact that I can't get a good
grasp of what the game is it's kind of
exciting to me because it means it will
be a more authentic like representation
of how she felt and and what the
emotions behind it by the PS is in real
life
no just goes to show you tormented
Alice's buying sea salt you day one very
positive reception to that game yeah so
nice range between that and anthem and
battle know that like NBA was right
after my favorite showing of the press
conference popped Crawdaddy says I can't
believe command & Conquer finally coming
back as a worthless you put mobilegame
ten damn years they've let it lie
dormant and now we get a repeat of
Dungeon Keeper mobile the RTS genre
needs a shot in the arm can EA go a
single
RTS has had multiple shopping here
you're just not paying attention look
back at they are billions look at total
war Warhammer look at any number of RTS
games in the last few years deserts of
Kharak that's untrue but yeah I don't
know why they devoted so much time to
disturb the conference yeah and come
into conquered just let it be there red
alert 2 is one of my favorite games
general zero hours a great game it has
its how many games they're now 18 I
think yeah just let them let them be I
can't believe how long I think it's
saying like let's not be unfair to the
game like the showing of it was annoying
the way they present it it's like
doesn't need to be presented it in a
shout casting away yeah the game itself
none of us have played it who can say
whether it could be good like who knows
I think the thing that people are
walking away with they're more annoyed
that firstly it's a mobile game but who
knows give it a chance
it could be good if you know I don't
expect it to be amazing but give it a
chance
who why the reason you know that people
are annoyed is they spent so much time
on it yeah and like after 5-10 minutes
on this mobile game it felt like just
killing time I don't think you can
completely turn away people's criticisms
about it like after 10 years there was
another command & Conquer game that they
were gonna do a few years ago they end
up caning like I remember playing a demo
of that on PC again yeah so like
obviously people are gonna be annoyed
and I think EA doesn't also have the
best reputation with stuff like this
because you remember having to Dungeon
Keeper Dungeon Keeper was a catastrophe
it EA needs to show people that what
they're gonna do a good-faith effort
with command & Conquer and I feel like
this presentation was very misjudged in
who they would show it to so I don't
think lucky can completely dry off right
drupal's complained but something like
obviously you have to take everything
with a pinch of salt yeah it's such a
huge property commander character that I
grew up with I have no problem with them
almost leaving it behind but they have
the brand recognition but I don't even
know if this generation of like people
playing games really command conquerors
ever around their mind that much like a
we're thinking like people I grew up on
like command & Conquer Red Alert 3 like
console kind of entries like that but
I don't know I mean when I say like they
devoted too much time to it that's
assuming that they would have other
stuff to show which I think they if they
did they would have why did they
shoutcast this yeah I mean like at the
risk of sounding quite selfish like why
it seems like any weird decision to show
this often spend as much time where show
where they know hardcore gamers are
watching like how many players are
watching this right so by showing it off
all you stand to do is upset the people
the hardcore out there who remember
command & Conquer and now are watching
you turn it into a mobile game yeah when
all you could have done was just said we
had we have this you know
come on Akaka game coming to mobile here
it is for a hot two minutes and then
just pay Apple the money to feature it
on the App Store and you've done your
job this seems like a very much like
patting out moment for the 48 press
conference which was unfortunate do we
want to talk about speaking of briefly
mentioning games and then kind of
leaving them behind
respawn stoic Vinnie Zamzam got my blood
flowing like the residue got a game name
the titanfall enthusiasts of the staff
are in here right now and so it seems
kind of funny like Vince's demeanor he
was kind of acknowledging that it was a
weird format almost or he was high I
don't think he was high but he so Jedi
fallen order is the Star Wars game I'm
working on that's pretty much all we
know
it's set during the dark times between
Revenge of the Sith and a new hope yep
presumably but also before rogue one
that's pretty much it one of the tweets
that lost but someone was saying we
surprised the lack of Star Wars given
there was they touched on Battlefront
they touched on this game yeah it was
like considering how big the deal is the
deal is running out in a couple years
mode of game they even mention it yeah
didn't even mention motive or the
open-world one
need were we surprised that there wasn't
more Star Wars chat or do you think even
EA themselves are considering guys Star
Wars fatigue we can't keep doing this
every year I don't see EA is
acknowledging that we have fatigue but I
mean it seems like they were trying to
capitalize on the solo hype if it exists
with Battlefront to which we can talk
about which actually I'm I was kind of
excited by what I saw there um I I did
want more though I wonder if you if you
could say that they were comparing
themselves like last III where was all
about bowel front yeah maybe they were
trying to just separate themselves a
little more but this at a certain spot
by the way his aura came out the Ewok
one it's a blast and yeah see what you
will about Bal front they're still
working with it
this all looks pretty damn good yeah the
squad stuff sounds really interesting
that was probably the most exciting to
you for me at least sounds like they're
doubling down on on areas that need to
attention I don't know the Clone Wars
are coming was like in some PC files so
there are people who love this game
right what's that way this has been
what's that kid begging podracer forget
his name Anakin's coming yeah so
actually that does excite me they're
bringing squads to battlefront two right
away they were pretty honest that they
messed up yeah like we know we I don't
know if that's gonna bring I'd never
play battlefront 2 at all not a single
second of it
preview events anything you know like as
of right now like I played again a
little bit of that you walk mode it's
it's how the game should have launched
yeah like it's all there the progression
is strong enough they they may do a
little too late arguably but yeah I
don't know that was at least it's at
least nice to see them working with that
gay people are still really into it and
I can guarantee a bunch of fans who of
Star Wars Battlefront which lost their
[ __ ] over that degrees they briefly
mentioned a new mode that sounds like a
grand operations equivalent you're
you're progressively taking or
destroying new
stardestroyers yeah sorry
they're putting attention into the
starfighter assault which I would argue
is like the best part Battlefront
because they've got criterion to do the
flight controls so it feels great the
flying is top-notch so yeah I mean I'll
definitely check that out it's free yeah
Sports oh yeah there was a bit Wales to
devs one cup guy is the anyway for cup
[Music]
ladies team people really liked shout
out to our hometown warriors in the
finals last night but then what was the
name of that kid was another young sick
or something like that's another thing
please stop trying to tell the story of
like sports tournament players know
firstly they're boring secondly no one
cares missed his graduation to play in
the Toro Khazar University cloud
streaming stuff yes that is a huge thing
yeah so like that that is gonna be a
theme for a lot of people I think this
III the services side of it Microsoft's
definitely gonna go huge crackdown 3
cloud save some destruction sony's going
to attempt it and we were talking about
this earlier it's like they're they've
bought they're bolstering their online
kind
like games game serving as services so
that you know that everyone's trying to
take a shot at Steam now and now now
they're doing cloud service gaming so
and the interesting thing about it was
they were talking about old games coming
to a bunch of devices and they talked
about extending experiences as well as
creating new experiences makes us sound
like they've got like new entirely new
games coming out only be delivered
through cloud services as well as taking
stuff like FIFA and maybe even anthem
and exploring how they can be played on
any device anywhere through cloud
services about origin which is great but
also other developers like Warner
Brothers is on there right now right
yeah how much of that market they're
gonna try them in a place it's crazy how
when Microsoft's original vision for
Xbox one came out it was all this stuff
that's what they were going funding
towards it a long time hashtag to tweet
to devs one-cup Microsoft on their long
time bringing back anything else oh we
missed unravel - we touched on it yes
it's available to play now go check it
out I'm sure Pete loves these game
releases he's our reviews editor during
the show I'm really disappointed in the
way that they did the it's available now
because I feel like you could have like
you've had the lovely dev who did the
original unravel reveal like he was so
happy to be that another studio in
addition lamplight was like I think we
all remember last time Yosef was on
stage asks do you think dead space can
be rebooted at this stage by a new
studio or is it gone forever like a dead
space for or reboot it could be I loved
what visceral did I would be very
hesitant about it I would love it just
to give it another chance I was so weird
I would love a new game but I would do
I'd love the visceral game so much I
would rather rematch it would be tricky
for a new studio to do it but in a world
where Resident Evil came back as good as
in a world where Capcom made a good
Resident Evil yeah and I'm surprised
more people haven't been I mean people
have been between silent hill's going
away it was such an impressing time
before than resin well 7 comes out and
knocks out of the park is incredible
like that's kind of like giving me faith
that anyone can do everything yeah but I
feel like if a game like rage can get a
sequel in this day and age the brand
recognition doesn't have to be as huge
as it was like and you
dead space sorry guys were busy turning
command & Conquer into a mobile game
yeah no time for dead space right now
let's start work and I thought it looks
a little more anthem or maybe just about
as much anthem anthem as I thought more
mobile games than I thought I am
surprised that the Sims didn't show
because they have obviously the seasons
expansion pack and if you saw that thing
I'm ready to play incredible so there
was a great ass credit for the other day
and it was like what is the the ongoing
drama in your hobby that other people
might not know about and the top comment
was there's a big thing happening with
the Sims right now because they're
releasing this season's expansion pack
our people are worried no they did show
Sims doing their pre-show just someone
stepping in the snow and nothing from
like PopCap no unfortunately no skate
for no snow no extra key criterion I
guess I'll stay were just working on
okay there was there was some skiing
teased in battle yeah I thought they
would go more into battlefield but I
guess they're saving it from Microsoft
yeah Marsh 940 says did EA meet your
expectations or Lefty disappoint of
something that you thought would be
there but wasn't personally anthem was
there so my expectations were like my
expectations of anthem and I'm still
excited for the game I enjoyed what I
saw yeah and I'm just very very excited
about that and also a sea of solitude
was a surprise yeah it was a very
pleasant one so I actually like despite
the pitfalls like the thing about EAS
conferences is their games cover such a
wide variety of like general or the
audiences and genres it's very difficult
to totally get one press conference that
can hit all those
successfully and make it cohesive and I
think that is is something that they
have struggled with for years and I
think it's something they're still
struggling with but for the things that
were there for me yeah yeah good I think
they did pretty well aside from the
command conquer thing like not to just
jump on and beat a dead horse but I
don't I don't see the point of that
theory if they punched in and out of
that thing and no one would have really
said much yeah and then move on to what
was next FIFA yeah yeah I mean similar
to Lucy says like we got anthem you know
we got CEO solitude which is great they
could have like dial down the how long
you spend talking about FIFA in in and
other sports games outside of the game
itself yeah like we don't need context
of a person rising you know changing
their lives by playing compare sports
yes it's inspiring if you're into that
stuff but I think this is the show to
show it but overall I think I think they
did pretty well they are we are gonna be
playing battlefield and anthem hands on
down at e3 if not already I know Aaron's
already down there so we will be doing
more chats throughout the week of course
we have two more conferences tomorrow
tomorrow morning Microsoft kicks off at
is it a I think it's a round so we'll be
doing like one pre-show right around
like noon 12:30 again so obviously come
back for that and then tomorrow night
tomorrow evening will be Bethesda a
specific time and we'll be covering all
those we'll also have a bunch of videos
from throughout the year rolling about
those games and we'll have like demo is
going up throughout the week and news
like our news team is outside right but
not outside but in the room outside of
here right now if you want to catch up
anything you missed so and thank you so
much for all the questions that was
awesome and we're gonna be doing that
throughout all the conference's yes now
we got our stage show later this week
III is officially underway it's going
well so far I hope it continues to go
well there's a few hitches in EA's
stream itself there was no yarny looked
like they were using or unravelled
looked like they were doing some god
mode stuff I don't know what they were
doing I just came to make mine of Tanks
yeah I wish that respawn I wish that we
see more what they were doing then he
Sam what's he got up his sleeve
takes it off and it's just doing
foot walk alright anyway thank you
everybody so much for joining us again
we will be back tomorrow with Microsoft
and Bethesda which I'm pretty excited
for but and in the meantime keep sending
questions in and get up-to-date on all
our news and we really appreciate you
stopping by we will see you throughout
the week
[Music]